hello everybody we are here it is
Monday
my here we
go it's Monday thank you for coming to
the
show oh we're have a great week of shows
for
you oh today we we have so much good
stuff to talk about and to joke about
well have so much fun the weather's
beautiful not a cloud
[Music]
Insight yeah thank you
everybody I'm sure I'm not the only one
that's had this song stuck in my head
all weekend and it is so good it is
actually so
good shout out to the jersey
lawmen and Vampira X o XO our winners of
the Fantastic uh tournament we H that we
had on uh
Friday yeah although Sam I have to tell
you um it
wasn't that song that dominated the
space in my mind this weekend it was
frankly G chick fortnite do you have
that Zach I can pull it real quick
because we're going to need cuz that was
in my in my head that's a dammer you
want the remix or you want her no I want
her original
okay that's the one I mean of all the
beautiful stuff we heard and Sam
is in my
head uh but anyway guys thank you for
being here we got a great show we got I
hope you guys like the thumbnail
actually uh this one was particularly
good can you send it to me CAM I want to
appreciate it on screen and frankly I'm
surprised we never made this comparison
earlier because they fit so well
together I've had I've had this in my
mind for a minute it's seamless the
chamber but now it's out baitman that's
his name right Patrick baitman Patrick
baitman and David Dober I mean h how
much fudging did you do to make this
look like one face how much uh just on
the nose that's it just the nose nose a
little bit golly
dude it's crazy so that's uh do brook
and uh baitman mhm
obviously they have the same
laugh with the tongue and
everything so um apparently he's hurt
another
person he's they're coming out against
do it's the year is
2020 there's also some new James Charles
tea but I guess we're going to look into
that a little more
but I was like yo what year is it you
guys 2020 let's get Trisha in here and
talk about it what year is it
exactly
um here at the top last night we let the
rler talk even Livy D was getting rised
up by baby gron he said that her G was
so Ohio and
skib even Ka and I show speed hitting
the gritty
a grim is shaking fornite that's so true
though a grim is shaking
fornite that is so good Ian are you the
proud um you got to be proud man you got
to be beaming with pride I'm over the
moon yeah I was there for the
process you know she had a notebook she
was asking me for like hours you she was
asking for feedback like how could I
shoehorn in uh the gritty can I can I
give you a little uh a little trivia
that you could add to the genius profile
Ian and I were actually playing fortnite
while she was writing in the background
I could hear you heard that over the
headset wow the creation process yeah
did you guys win we always win yeah fat
dubs right in fortnite we actually won
that game I think you know what we lost
that one but I think it was only cuz
ninja was in it yeah t yeah ninja and
tfue us up yeah that's fine tfue
more like pu yeah that's what I'm saying
absolutely anyway um thank you Sam uh
quickly at the top here I want to say
that
um Black Friday is still
happening I don't know what's left but
let's take a look get your Christmas
shopping your holiday shopping in now up
to 60%
off um get it now
guys there's
also if you go to the the search thing
no not that how do we do
the there's a way to sort by like size
and stuff I don't filter where is
that I thought it would be here probably
on the Ben tab or maybe this filter this
filter do I need to open it all the
way we can work on
okay can work on making that a little
more accessible but any if you click
filter you can organ by size Color Price
I'm telling you guys you will find
something you love here at Teddy
fresh.com Black Friday sale
also if you want some of the Timeless H3
memorabilia the H3 trading cards are on
[Music]
sale all proceeds are going to the
crew get them now at TRD ng. shop got
them right here there it is there
there's all kinds of Beau they are yeah
those the ones that are being sent great
to you I think we're almost out of the
red
ones um so get them while they last the
green ones are are uncapped cuz it's a
pre-order kind of thing but the red ones
are the ones that'll show up before
Christmas and uh I think supplies are
dwindling fast I don't think there's
many left based on what I understand
like a couple hundred a couple hundred
you better get in there fast boys and
ladies and girls and everyone in between
here's a
sample so that's it all right Gambit
okay Gambit okay Gambit now that's
cool wow wow wow dude um one thing I
want to ask people have been saying
since I got this rash around my eyes
that oh you look you look sick you look
unhealthy something's wrong with you
what I don't understand is when Pete
Davidson has butthole eyes everyone
talks about how hot he is but when I get
butthole eyes then it's like don't come
near me what the his aren't red
right yes they are they're super
up sometimes they're red so like where
why what's the double standard I think
maybe it's not maybe it's not the
eyes you know what I mean like maybe
it's not the eyes that are making Pete
super hot maybe it's possible he it's in
spite he has sleepy eyes you don't look
sleepy hold on you said Olivia hold on
you said previously if I recall
correctly that you like guys with butt
that butthole look specifically I'll be
honest like I look at him and I think he
has beautiful eyes like I look at that
photo and I'm like wow look at his eyes
they're really pretty look these aren't
like really red it's more just like
darken like he's really tired I think
he's it's more emaciated cuz you said
you like starving heroin boys I don't
think she ever said that the type varies
however that has been a type that has
existed in my past well he definitely
embodies that okay so it's less red and
more just emaciated mhm so maybe get
yours to be a little less red a little
bit more emaciated then we'll talk
okay they look now I'm not gu and just
not so it's not weird I'm not trying to
get Olivia to say she's attracted to me
oh my God absolutely I'm just saying in
general the the the uh audience I'd
prefer some you know more compliment
he's hot oh my God look at him he looks
terrible he looks he look look how
hot he is with falling your eyes make
you feel prettier
not my eyes make me feel like I have
hamburger eyeballs dude I'm
seeing people in the chat point out that
it it may be partially because of the
fact that he supposedly allegedly has a
giant dick too okay well you just
haven't heard the rumors but people say
that about me too well I've heard rumors
but they're not the same kind of rumors
what what do you mean by that it's going
in the opposite direction you've not who
have you heard rumors about that you say
saying it on the show all the time I
never said I have a small
dick somebody pull up the Compilation
All right I may have said I have a tiny
Jewish dick yes God I have small dick
energy can you guys please stop using my
own words against me also also this is
what's been going around whoa whoa and
again where's the Ethan's hot
compilation no what the this jeez Ethan
wants chocolate yeah me when I see uh oh
brother Where Art Thou chocolate this is
right before you know you hated to hear
it but this is the face you make when
you start floating to the pie yeah I
don't hate to hear it I I I I accept it
that's I'm excited you know I'm ready I
want chocolate damn it means you care
sure do care wish more people cared as
much as I do I wish I had chocolate
right now we have a
bunch it's not the yummy you can make
your wish I want or brother chocolate
yeah I want more brother Chate I got
this email from the o brothers guys this
morning cuz I keep saying where's my
chocolate you just sent me
this I was like don't you think you're
leaning into it a little too hard there
buddy still haven't got any chocolate
from
him um what else I got here another uh
important note to make at the top of the
show is that for everybody to go to
Google and type here I'll do it we can
all do it together go to
Google and search failure podcast just
that and then what I want you guys to do
is look
for um our
website I only say to search failure
podcast because it's easier to typing in
that super long
URL it's so easy to do a typo and then
you one typ when you're done you know so
go here and then click our website and
then give it a read this is to people
who haven't read it or people who want
to brush up on this uh for uh upcoming
podcast what was it that you Googled
thank you failure podcast yeah
yeah why did I see J shett on there wait
what where wait scroll down scroll down
I just saw J you did not keep going
right there jcast the bro he's
following get the out of my
life why is Jay shett here one week ago
too j j shett is raiding above Ryan's
podcast more than us yeah all right I'll
click it I'll take the it again I think
Envy is the thief of Joy where we run
into problems when we stop admiring
those people and we start wanting what
they have or feeling like I should have
gotten what they got organizational
psychologists want to bring in
bestselling author Wharton's number
onewe
that's awesome bro what the why do
you look like Santa Claus from like the
' 8S Coca-Cola commercials bro at that
those are first of all those are Pepsi
colors
clearly what is that he's always in like
the craziest designer clothes like can
you be humble he's fit you're really
going to have a book in the background
called B air Virgil
uho oblo ablo ablo designer o and then
like what are these what are these
things are these
Remos uh those are streams yeah okay bro
it's not an Academy Award chill the
out I know if they're streams cuz we
don't have any so I don't know what they
look what are those he's not getting
awards from anyone
else Jesus bro you seriously going to
come out here in that
sweater start I can't wait to go on this
journey with you thank you so much for
subscribing it means the world to me the
bestselling author and host the number
one Health and Wellness he's on the old
like why is growth important and I know
it sounds it may sound like a stupid
question it may sound like a it is a
stupid to talk about especially on a
show like this but I find the people I
talk to do we need a second angle
profile shot that is so pretentious I
call this out every time we don't need a
second profile shot it allows you to cut
around seamlessly okay well we don't
around bro we do it like we never
miss if we need to cut around something
I hit a button man right cut
cut
uh so we got some stats here too oh you
want me to pull these up yeah this is
our article yeah I've been going through
the stats and quite frankly that um
what's it called the average engagement
time is pretty low we need that up a
little bit I'm spend more time reading
the article yeah read it twice you know
as you remember what to further right to
further like we should add more I don't
know maybe so an additional information
as it's released as we learn
more it'll be like a live update Vlog
yeah we'll add more information yeah mhm
yeah ni I like that very good do you
guys want to maybe I would just like if
I just watch J shett podcast because
apparently it's so much better than this
one maybe I'll just play his podcast
here maybe maybe people finally come
watch our show when it becomes more like
J shett and less like me you're talking
idolize being average they think it's
good enough good enough is good I find
that we are wired often to want things
to stay exactly the same we like how
they are why should we get better why
should anything get better we should be
sa nobody believes that
Jay oh I just think I'm totally cool
just being a lame stupid idiot all the
time I don't want to proove anything
said
nobody everybody wants to to do better
be better at something man and it's not
all just about making money Jay it's not
about financial success Jay it's about
personal growth
sometimes I don't know why I have to
teach this to
youed with what we have and often in the
guise of contentment and peace there's a
sense of lethargy and complacency that
well we don't need to grow because
you're just being greedy so I'm
presenting a spectrum of ideas there
happy for you to dive into any of those
but why does getting better and
improving matter at all this is fast why
doesn't what okay all right go ahead
dude I you can take the bait Go ahead
nobody's ever asked me that before and I
frankly I think I've taken for granted
oh look how happy he is yeah that's so
annoying look how why did he
have to say that to him it's you know
what I mean like look how happy he made
him and that pisses me off that's so
annoying look at this frankly I
think I've taken for granted that growth
is just inic enjoyable and motivating I
mean I think you made a case that no one
needs that
profile shot and it's out oh guys no no
no don't do that what do you mean I
didn't ask for that Prof we always had
this no we have not had that that's your
favorite shot you say that's the special
shot you're just trying to distinguish
yourself from Shetty I get it he's the
king you want to carve your own space in
the podcast sphere but um guys I was say
I think it's advis think it's advisable
you use the shot you really think like
oh this is interesting okay now this is
more interesting no dude it's trickery
stop one shot in my professional opinion
you you need the
shot I'm not going to allow this I'm
going to do like this try to show me the
side shot oh it looks even better
wait no that's the front show the side
[Music]
she yeah there okay who's got a at least
it's different at least you see in the
back of my head not the side at least
it's a different person perspective as
Gary ve would
say which is so important all right go
ahead I want to listen maybe some people
are not motivated by growth I think that
why do you say growth like that wa
I mean I think you made a case that
maybe some people are not motivated by
growth that was crazy why would why
did you say that like that yeah D he's
so annoying Zach you got to pull that
you got it and motivating I mean I think
you made a case that maybe some people
are not motivated by growth a growth
what happened bro what what was that man
come
on I think that where I my push back on
that is to say we live in a world that
glorifies performance so you know people
feel like if they want to be respected
or celebrated they need to win a medal
they need to earn a trophy uh all right
I'm out listen the one person I really
want to see on J shett is a boogie
2988 I think that they would have a
really fascinating conversation Zach um
I did work at a small gaming store back
in 2006 2007 I am disabled uh recognized
by the state of Arkansas but also the
United States government there's that
now the downside of that is I am
extremely depressed so there's some
mental health issues that we bring to
the table no okay all
right not that not that good
actually
it's not that good and then physically I
I am morbidly obese I have no references
uh no work history all right it's and no
education lay it on a little and when
you Google my name you might see rumors
that I beat my ex-wife and I'm also a
pedophile should mention I'm also a
felon Jesus right what's the new oh gosh
oh you found the sweater nice how much
is this I bet
1,300 you're going to sit before
us a moded isn't he supposed to be like
a Buddhist what is Buddhism say no he's
Hindu Oh I thought he was a monk or
something was it Hindu monk okay monk
all right what does Hindu monks have to
say about
$1,350 Stella McCartney sweaters it's
Stella McCartney yeah probably that
looks fire on Stella
McCartney okay
Buddhist love Stella McCartney and not
Buddhist monks love you really you
really think Stella would be the words
were jumbled in my
brain everyone loves it oh
God
okay anyway listen I didn't even want to
be here talking about J shett I
literally was just talking about Ryan's
podcast and somehow pipeline me into
this it's radicalizing me this is you
remember how like you remember how like
white nationalism videos were being
recommended right yeah it was like a
radicalization pipeline that's what this
is yeah you're in the shete the chedy
pipeline and shed's pipe what the
dude pipe and
shete that was a really
really let's go to popular who's who
maybe some people are not motivated by
growth
growth I am I am motivated by G what
what is by growth gr what is that accent
does anybody have any it sounds like a
surfer bro he he sounds American I don't
think he's I think he was saying other
words to sounds like a cartoon character
talks like this he's got that teay
dude growth the growth maybe some people
are not motivated by
growth wait his number one guy twice who
is this guy wait we got to reach out who
is this guy Dr Joe they love
Dr Joe dispenser cuz he
dispenser hold on can we reach out to Dr
Joe I want to get in the Shetty pipeline
Joe those people lose their Free Will
let's see what is he on about let me see
programs and it's that uncompromising
will where you keep right get on with I
think the most beautiful and by the way
this is oh this from 5 months ago by
growth and growth growth powerful thing
in the world is a repetitive thought
but sometimes the most dangerous thing
absolutely and we think about the most
beautiful things we create is because
we're obsessed with this new idea and
this new thought that we want to build
something but at the same time we know
countless people who they have a thought
every day that says I'm unlovable I'm un
Jay I'm here I want to hear from the
guests you don't have to monologue this
long man everybody already loves you you
don't have to win anyone over uh Joe
dispenser right interational speaker
doctor of Chiropractic no no way are you
serious are you serious he got in a
cycling accident accident in 1986 and he
checked out the hospital and worked on
uh having his mind heals vertebrae no
six compressed yeah
no he was left in a serious cycling
accident that left him with six
compressed vertebrae doctors told him he
may never walk again and recommended
spine surgery inste
said the doctor claims he checked
himself out of the hospital and
dedicated himself to reconstructing his
Verte with his mind no that's
sick dude no way this guy is isn't that
Dr Sno Theory no do no his theory is
that stress can create back can manifest
in back pain not using your brain to
rearrange your bones together
man this guy is like the ultimate
chiropractor right here like that's
crazy do
that my
growth
gri well this seems like all the more
reason to have him on I'm G to call him
out Bring I want to talk to Dr Joe I'm
here to dismantle the shed pipeline I'm
going to break his back again I'm going
to sabotage you know how they didn't it
happen like the ukrainians or Russians
blew up a pipeline MH I'm going to do
that it's just a war between me and
Shetty and I'm yes this is like
the nordstream pipeline explosion
[Applause]
yes I don't deserve love in my life if
someone's having a negative repetitive
thought specifically around if anyone's
thinking hm my back is broken in
five places what do you do with your
mind to think to fix that please bro you
guys selfworth what they believe they
deserve in love where did they start
with that thought well we think
primarily uh 90% of the time we think
the same thoughts as we thought the day
before the challenge with that is the
thought that you keep thinking over and
over again becomes people are calling
him Doctor Strange I remember about that
it's sort of the similar story in that
he he like up his back and he
healed it with his mind oh true yeah cuz
in his world magic Lear and he learned
it from a monk right it's cuz they do
magic do you believe in magic J sh I do
now oh man J you do with your mind this
is dude this man is like
engineered perfectly to piss me
off man you know who we really need to
get on this podcast is
fidas oh yeah I think that would be a
clashing stop with the side profile Ian
it looks great it's not funny and ask
for that interesting it's
interesting what do you think
uh I'm experiencing the other and then I
was with Olia it's interesting how you
compare how you comp when another new
person potentially comes in the your
life it's like you compare what if we
did is she more
beautiful well how is yeah J shett I'd
like to see how you handle that kind of
interview that's the I deal
with
Fus
fidus
Fus did you have this as
well all right anyway welcome to a stre
podcast happy Monday everybody
who wants to cure their broken
spine with their brain today
boy
mhm I'm feeling frisky boy I'm I'm about
to around and fix my broken bones
with my brain
[Music]
today yeah um thank you to yeah we're
going to be talking to the Jersey law
man and vampir xx XOXO
later I have questions for them but I
have so much to get to so let's just
jump right into it X
xxon first of all we've had a heated
debate about Mr BEAST's body language
when he went on the um Andrew
Schultz
podcast but a
new we have a new evidence coming
out why is it so far away I thought it
was okay no here so here here they are
Jesus that podcast looks I think I know
where that is I
think I think that's where Howie Works
my best friend my my
helper my understanding is it's in Mr
BEAST's uh place oh they went to be okay
that also makes sense it's a temporary
setup so they
okay but what the who sits like
that uh how are you nobody can defend
that okay first of
all I happily defend that uh the other
um the other host also has his feed up
it's just a feed up kind of podcast do
you think he's that far away though it's
hard to tell cuz we're straight on like
he couldn't be further I mean have you
ever sat where you're like as far as
possible it's weird I'm doing it right
now I'm literally doing it right now
like it's not even comfortable so I saw
a comment it was very good it said it's
like Jimmy just read a book about how to
dominate the space or something you just
watched that Ted talk about power poses
mhm so I don't know at first this person
said I thought Ethan was being hard for
having his feet up but then what the
hell is this it's even more aggressive
on the Colin and Samir
podcast he looks like yeah here it is he
looks like he just read a book about how
to assert dominance so
true so I don't know what this means I
mean he is uh are they even recording
look how is he they can't be recording
right now look how far away he is from
the the mic yeah it's like the audio guy
must hate him he's probably laed up Mr
Beast don't need no mic he's just
projecting he's yelling like six feet
the god mic all times I don't think
Beast would wait a second with these
guys unless they're recording you know
what I mean he's got things to do I kid
Mr Beast though we love Beast I make
that clear that we love them and that's
why we kid him how much do you love him
a lot enough to skip this next
link uh absolutely
not no well I seek truth that's all I've
ever said to do and if that's my friends
if these are people I respect it admire
I will always bring the truth to the
people because I am not swayed by
politics by uh impersonal fightings or
even sometimes you know look here for
example this is a massive exposed make
squid game yeah 42 what the Jimmy
where's your pants whoa you're what is
going on here
bud this is just unforgivable why what
why have you done this dude I'm
surprised you found see his balls
although to be fair I would say the
dominance he's exerting now is
definitely better than this maybe that's
why he puts his feet
up what the man I can see your
balls an that's his actual
right there we're like 1 cm away
from his I think what's
happening though after staring at this
for so long over the weekend he has
flesh colored pants right yeah it ises
unfortunately so YouTube moderators
watching this it's not actually dick and
balls he uh he can do anything he
wants yeah he's at that point he just
pulls up naked what are you going to
arrest Mr Beast for public
indecency he's a millionaire honestly I
think he's showing off his legs I think
he knows what works and he's letting us
know about it that one you can see a
little
better yeah and all the other angles uh
from this podcast it's obviously he's
wearing shorts I genuinely thought that
when you said that was real though when
I first saw beast beast I guess that is
a form of Don just to come balls out
that's I think as Alpha as it comes slap
him on the chair and call it a day
clothes
dude we love you
Beast good job on the
wells I was reading about Mr Beast
because of course people always complain
when he does stuff and I wouldn't say
people complain more so like they're
angry that a YouTuber is doing more
humanitarian efforts than their
government has like if you go to his his
uh new video about the
wells I was reading separately that he's
actually
provided drinking water for half a
million people that didn't have it
before which is absolutely crazy
yeah that is like a significant um I
mean that's some good that's a good deed
right there but sure at where and what
what where was it was it what country
was it in or is it
across I'm not familiar with this uh
latest video countries almost
so yeah he went across um I guess Africa
in places where they don't have
accessible drinking water and built a
100 Wells down to the you know
groundwater wow and gave they these
people have half a million now have
access to drinking water so I mean godd
damn balls out Jimmy you get those balls
out bro balls out for Jimmy
what's the gorilla's
name har yeah F my B harambe my
dick's out for Jimmy now and you know
he's got a thigh slapper man oh
yeah wearing those shorts man that's
confidence right there you think Jimmy's
got a hog is that what you're saying
yeah dude he got some grou or something
short if you wear short shorts like that
wouldn't it imply the opposite there's
not much I mean there's not much to
cover yeah I mean there's it's super
tight there's nothing there's nowhere
for anything to hide down show it off I
don't know I think you got larger
balls yeah I think they hang low why do
you think that hang low why do you think
that I've seen an alternate angle yeah
yeah oh well swinging droopers oh yeah
for sure all the busy that's the Beast
balls the Beast busy love listen you're
a young man and I have to tell you that
one day your balls will swing low as
well my friend hey and I can't wait
why you know just embrace it you can't
wait for your balls to drag on the floor
like gorilla Knuckles yeah um um I it's
exciting just change you
know life stagnant it's true yeah so
true I have big
balls cool um create let's see
here oh this was a nice little clip that
came out over the weekend uh
um I don't know what this isn't a Karen
this is a something else I don't know
what you'd call this but it is something
let's take a listen and discuss it after
can you not touch my car like that can
you give me a phone please what can you
give me a phone I want to send a
text what are you doing sitting outside
this house what are you doing I live
here you don't live here what are you
doing can you get your hands off my car
please no
please what are you doing leave go away
what are you doing go
away be the
zimb bro he turned into bbo grabing for
the ring get away from here that's a
witch that was bbo that was
B you do yeah can you get your hands off
my car please what the hell please what
are you do leave go away what are you
doing give me my prees I be to
Zim you stupid a pimp did he
say it sounded like so is the guy is
this a racist thing happening oh maybe I
didn't even understand what she was
saying I I think it's a guy yeah it's
not a dude I think it's a dude a woman
no that's a woman that's old lady hell
no that's a guy no no it's a guy it's a
lady ain't no way no it's not well let
me watch it again mine I for some reason
I thought it was can you not touch my
car like that can you give me a phone
please got earrings got gorgeous
earrings phone I want to send a
text what are you doing sitting outside
this house it sounds like a man to me I
mean whatever I don't your voice is just
husky if you look at the very beginning
she has earrings on not that a man can
wear earrings but they like Are you
seriously want to retract that now or
later men wear earrings dude and I'll
say it to both cameras go ahead men wear
earrings too and clearly this is a
fashionable guy who's been around and
car cares about the way he looks this is
a man baby hell no I think you might be
wrong though Ethan the guy the guy who
posted this clip uh it said it's a a
woman what where did you say that if you
click on the post and scroll down it
said I tried to put the window up but
uh there's a part two our
gu I tried to put the window up but the
pushed it down should have left it where
it was I don't see a gender go down
there is a part two but I got a bit
angry so I will not see the light of day
um one I want that yo you got to
released that part too she called me a
pimp okay all right well he could have
been wrong too I mean what the he's
seeing what we're
seeing you you're with me right love no
that's a old lady dude no wait somebody
backed me up no I thought it was a guy
yeah it's a guy yeah Zach had guy in the
dock I I erased guy and put person cuz I
thought a person is uncontroversial yeah
true we agree there hold on let's see
let's see you live here what are you
doing can you get your hands off my car
please no please what are you doing
leave go away what are you doing go
away Zim stupid little pimp get away
from here dude that is so first of all I
guess I I should acknowledge first that
there is a chance this is just some a
sad case of dementia happening so we
extend our hearts and our minds yeah but
that other hand it could also just be a
racist yeah it could be said in a
different way
yeah well we have always have to do a
pull poll if it's a guy or a girl can
you not touch my car like that can you
give me a phone please what about a
non-binary queen I will add that as a
third okay right will I say gender how
would I word this assign what you could
say is this aign female at Birth assign
male at
Birth I don't know what are we I don't
know if that's dicey CU I feel like I
think you just say man woman or
nonbinary you got three options okay you
can whatever it is uh they look like
they're related to Jimmy sville that's
and yes all right here we go and they
were mean for no reason it's
text what are you doing to outside this
house what are you doing I live here you
don't live here what are you doing can
you get your hands off my car please no
please what are you do let uh leave go
away what are you do break for
quite heavily here be to Zim you
stupid little pimp get away from here
dude that was so
theatrical that's scary as
old people are scary sometimes bro
okay so so the I see the people out in I
think it's a guy what only
14% Zach me and you
are but that's not even represented cuz
me and Zach thought it was a guy and
what there's like nine of us here and
that's got to be at least 25 30% it's
definitely a woman I'm surprised you
don't why does it matter it doesn't
matter mattering is not the point
nothing on this show matters all that
it's a disagreement and I and it's just
about who's right and who's wrong yeah
that's what matter who said anything
about mattering getting a dunk over
you're watching the wrong show
bro if you're looking for meaning in any
of this this is the pettiest show on
YouTube literally doesn't matter at all
nothing exactly welcome to the
existential crisis P that's right Are
you seriously asking does it matter all
right I'm uh I'm wrapping this poll up I
think okay who's this Dan is this a guy
or a
girl hold on he's got earrings oh
Dan there were other context clues Ethan
I'm kidding you other cont playing drums
that said you look like a freaking woman
dude lady earrings those are
gay damn dude lady I need to I need
to get my hands at some Alpha raring
quick mhm you got to start wearing short
taned shorts dude flesh like a mask sheh
color everything dude matching My Flesh
color exactly like to the point where
you got to get like a bikini
[Laughter]
wax this man Ethan hates being wrong are
you kidding me right now in the
chat stoping do you not know anything
about me oh we switched to the other
angle don't I don't want to talk Ser
this
[Music]
angle you come here on this Monday and
talk to me like this doesn't matter
Ethan hates being
wrong try growing up well adjusted in my
family
capiche my my brother and my dad
will
argue
about
if there's MSG in the Chinese
food you guys don't understand that
house that I was grown up in man that
sounds brutal your brother and your dad
arguing about no you don't understand
there is I wish El was here I just got
abused
bro the constant constant
arguing yeah the constant ones uping of
just the need to be right right it's
it's infected my soul and I'm the least
bad about it of anyone in my family I
grew up in the trenches man and how dare
you come and be ableist about my
childhood Dr trauma recognized by the
state also United States government
there's that no the downside to that is
I am extremely depressed so there's some
we all have our baggage bro and then
physically I I am morbidly obese I we
all have our baggage man uh no orchest
and no education and when you Google my
name it's not a suffering Olympics
dude you know you don't have to top
everything I say Boogie I'm calling
Ela you're in the void
now ELA pick up it's
urgent
all right this is I got to move on she's
busy what the anyway uh where where
are we so shout out to the
um to the to the
lady to the lady out there in England
and all British people the world over we
love shout out positive influence on the
planet from the beginning of time to
modern day that's not your ID the
English have not instigated a
single bad thing in this world
period And I uh as and it being the
cradle of civilization as we know
it I stand with the English
people against any and all accusation
watching
aena oh
wait they do it like this right just
don't do it sideways they do this don't
they yeah I don't know told her to say
buya
buha uh oh yeah this was a crazy weird
coincidence this dude we talked about uh
the Maga we are the people video We are
the world we are the world with big Nick
and all that yeah and so the guy who
produced it who put this whole thing on
who looks like a Wii
[Music]
Avatar he was recently in the news
because you almost blew up a
airplane the sh of California watch this
this so funny this is the
terrifying moment frantic cabin crew
tried to put out a fire on a JetBlue
plane after American Idol Star Jimmy
Levy's backpack exploded and burst into
flames footage Show's crew desperately
pouring water onto a smoldering bag
shortly after the music artist had woken
up to intense heat the former American
Idol Star said I thought someone tried
to attack me because I'm a known
political figure and musician but no
idiot
you dumbass what the fu us closer what
do you got in that backpack man
invation it appeared to be an overheated
portable charger in my
backpack what that is insane and he lift
us from the
ground wait do we believe that a
portable a overheated portable charger
causing a a flame I mean yeah they have
a warning about how many uh was it mamps
that you're supposed to bring on but
yeah you'd have to really it up for
it to do that CU I've never heard of
this Happ I mean I they I mean that's
why they don't let you bring batteries
over a certain size onto planes um okay
because of the fire risk so I don't know
it could have just been a could have
been a fluke yeah could have been a
fluke it's just funny that it's him what
does it mean they're wording in that
tiktock that his backpack exploded but
what but what does it mean though was it
mean yeah what mean it means that the
Deep State failed to take out a brave
Patriot because in this guy's world uh
God coordinates and orchestrates
everything so my question to you my
friend is what does it mean going to off
got the beard though the eyebrows of the
beard it's wild I love American Idol
Star said I thought someone tried to
attack me because I'm a known political
figure and musician but after investig
God can you imagine people going after
him cuz he's a threat to the social
order like all the
people the CIA is plotting to
assassinate his song was too powerful
man it brought too many people too many
patriots together oh it's so funny I
love that
[Music]
anyway thanks Big Nick play the Michael
Flynn
one
cler that
is that is 100% unedited right Zach
that's 100% raw I mean in their version
It's autotuned to but we have I
haven't touched
that so there it is there it is thank
you shout out
Maga shout out magga always working to
make a America better one exploding uh
backpack at a
[Music]
time um is anyone
hungry why am I I've been hungry lately
maybe I need to eat a bigger breakfast I
just have like fruit I had fruit and a
coffee that was it I an apple yeah
that's not very much apple starving dude
but like I got yeah I think I got to eat
an egg or something to fill me up more
so I'm like dying right now you know
what I'm saying going to need to break
those eggshells what do I want mhm you
guys can pitch stuff in Discord okay I
don't want to get I don't want to get
too deep into it right now where's your
dad love he's like doing things you know
byy no way he's at home watching this
isn't he no he's he's touring all the
comic book SL like uh role playing
stores dude your dad is awesome love
needs to take the hood off the hawk man
he need to fly free Tomy has a Warhammer
40K Army like a miniature Army is he
like magic the Gathering yeah with
yeah he likes magic of gathering I'm
going to try to get him some wait that's
sick yeah yeah he loves everything and
he plays World of Tanks he plays World
of Warcraft he does yeah that's how I
got started playing World of Warcraft yo
your dad got you mainlined into that
whoa yeah as a kid holy your
dad is the is so interesting and he
watches like twitch and all that what
yeah
yeah you know do you know no pixel it's
like the big RP
GTA GTA server he's on that oh no way
yeah you don't remember that Ethan that
was like the role playing GTA thing that
all the twitch streamers were doing for
a while they were doing like hate crimes
and on the same server as xqc okay right
yeah and he's interacted with holy
dude the hawk is a badass so is your dad
hardore Wild player not anymore no not
anymore no what does he do for a living
uh computer programming yeah your dad's
the man it's cool pretty cool I love him
does he work from home no no no he
probably could but no what a cool dude
yeah he's super cool dude you guys are
like you you have so much in common with
your dad I I I think it's cool yeah I'm
just like my dad everyone tells me you
guys have like the same interests and
stuff which I think is cool yeah my
carbon copy of him it's hard to admit I
wish yeah I I'm not going to
complain about my dad right now we've
all we've all heard enough about it well
I'll complain about mine real quick I
was just going to say it was so cool how
Love's Dad knew all of our names what
all of our jobs
went by one by one and talk to us I'm
like my dad does not know a single one
of your names like I'll be surprised if
he knows Ethan's name yeah that's kind
of where cuz like my dad is obsessed
with sports and he never not only did he
not show interest in my hobbies he like
openly like I would
say uh teased me for it it wasn't mean
but he teased me for being like a gamer
or even listen to hip-hop he's like what
is that back in the day mhm his opinion
has changed since then
um but uh my brother and sister are
obsessed with sports just like him and
so they have they connect on on
a on a level that I can't relate cuz I
hate Sports was it just Dodgers
or was he anything he loves it all he
loves football Dodgers Hockey baseball
he does it all man he's like a diard
UCLA fan right
yeah
yeah my sister and my dad both love
sports too and you don't and I don't SP
do you think that you it was a a why do
you think that you didn't get into it I
don't I feel like maybe it was Alex
claimed the athlete thing so I wasn't
really even thinking about doing it Alex
Alex is my sister oh she just was in
soccer and all that stuff so I was just
like hi sisters I'm GNA sing I'm going
to dance I think okay yeah I'm pretty
sure mine was was an act of
rebellion maybe subliminally for me I
think I didn't want to have the same
interest as him cuz I wanted to be
different you weren't like other girls
certainly wasn't yeah but I was that
you were that all right
enough but anyway it's super cool how
you and your dads have so much in common
I like that thank you nice it's very
nice he's he looks young too how old is
he um I don't want to say his exact age
but he's below 55 oh so he is Young yeah
he's very yeah oh that's so
nice that's awesome mhm love the hawk
yeah both my parents have never I feel
like the reason I have this job I follow
L this like all the way is because of my
parents are so open cuz I I was going to
go back to school and my parents when I
when I said what that I got hired here
as they were both very supportive and go
for it that's awesome full support I
will say your dad we when I arrived he
uh took me aside and was very grateful
for uh he says he's so happy that you
were able to come out here and be here
and like that it was so special and he
was so just happy and appreciative that
uh for the opportunity that we that for
you to come out here he did that yeah he
did that's nice yeah he was very very
sweet and genuine he didn't tell me that
that's very nice I knew I knew he was
happy but very wholesome yeah it was
really sweet we love the hawk yeah fly
free Hawk spread those wings man he'll
be
back hog is cool hwk is cool
dude there it
is getting teared up getting emotional
talking about
Hawk yeah but with my boys I'm take I'm
I'm specifically trying to like
show interest in all the stuff they like
you know what I mean like I want to do
the stuff that they like with them
instead of like forcing them to I don't
like anything though to be honest so
it's
easy but like Teddy's obsessed with this
game my sinking monsters
and so like I'm right there with him I
know everything about that game
that game is sick by the way do you sing
with the monsters no well so each
there's a bunch of different levels mhm
and you breed monsters on each different
level there's a bunch of different
monsters and they each have a different
role in a
song each island has a different song
and it's it is actually so cool it is so
cool has really good reviews I see dude
it is a freaking game people make music
with that too like actual good music you
seen those yeah that's sick there's a
whole singing monster universe it's
pretty incredible here's the top review
on that game on Steam is uh this makes
me want to neglect my
kids well that's sad it's not that
good um here's Jimmy uh you know with
his new well out there in Africa and we
we think he's doing really good work so
in this case it's forgivable in this
case he should be Flex in on that
well I think he could probably use
better construction near the drinking
water I don't know better construction
material maybe next
time doesn't look very reliable but
better than nothing it's better than
nothing
yeah it works it works
[Music]
um let's see what else we got oh this
one's crazy you guys Roman
Atwood when's the last time you heard
that name smile more remember
that I used to have a problem with this
guy cuz he he literally invented pranks
in the hood he is Mr pranks in the hood
and I thought it was so interesting how
he pivoted from like hardcore racist
like it's Joey salad's bad where in the
comments it's just all super racist like
of course black people act like that I
didn't know that was his origin oh he's
the king of that dude like look up
um siphoning
gas from
people's cars prank in the hood in the
hood you know where it's dangerous and
scary do you remember that dog
prank movie he made with
Vitali they did a lot together what did
they do they made like a a full uh movie
of just like Jack prank it was terrible
wait it was even in the theaters yeah
but it was a a colossal flop of course
it was it was really bad here um wait
it's still up on his channel holy I
would thought he would have erased this
in
embarrassment yo it's still up 55
million views so stealing people's gas
prak I'm pretty sure he must have
changed it cuz I'm pretty sure it used
to be in the hood but anyway here take a
look I see one in the description
explosive farts in the hood oh that's
yeah that's dangerous you don't want to
do that people's gas out of their car
but really it's just
water oh
oh by the way that is such an insane
thing to do to someone is it we getting
claimed not necessarily the claimed but
he's about to uh get into a pretty
physical altercation I don't know if
it's well anyway he he basically
pretends to steal people's gas which is
objectively a crazy thing to do and
then uh people some people are just
angry some people get violent and I mean
there's a good chance some of this is
even fake I don't know which makes it
worse cuz he like yeah doesn't make it
better no hell no yeah cuz he was
building like yeah he's making them
people look bad like Joey Sal when he
when you when he faked it it's like
right so so much worse Jesus um but yeah
the comments are wild but anyway I
always thought it was so interesting
that he pivoted from this to smile more
family
Vlogs I was like oh my god well there
was a transition phase where it was like
flashing children in public prank oh my
you're right I forgot about that one
that was a nice transition of family
content yes flashing kids at the park
prank he's he's wearing clothing but
what he does is he goes up the kids and
does it like he's flashing them and then
the parents come up in a panic and he's
like no psych I just I'm wearing clothes
no he's wearing a shirt that says don't
do drugs bro
it's it's so
nuts
like I'm sorry but that's still pretty
scary thing to run up to a kid and like
violently open your
robe that's crazy he makes like really
weird noises too
like it's
insane so he pivoted from this to family
smile more smile
more the so anyway that's neither
here nor there that's my background with
uh Roman
Atwood
but he's doing a podcast
now of
course what I love this what do we need
another white guy with a podcast I
wouldn't know anything about that I've
been doing it long enough I'm not you do
not include me we've been here for years
before the white dude in the podcast
meme
existed and frankly is that
true I think started this in like 2017 I
feel like we were the First YouTube
podcast dude or one of the specifically
like a big YouTube channel starting a
podcast yeah you may have goad
definitely yes everyone after you guys
did it everyone tried to do it and still
to this day they have not succeeded I
feel like this is so much more than more
than a podcast yeah I mean J shett is I
agree over the years it's certainly not
it's certainly evolved to something more
but you guys definitely made a template
of
it say what a I said you guys definitely
made the template of it oh thank you
yeah yeah I mean at the time when we
made it I was very unsure it was a big
risk I remember like I don't know if
anyone wants to watch a
podcast there it is and here we are so
anyway yada yada now Roman Atwoods uh
talking about how his dad made K
he's he what seems like he's accusing
his dad on his podcast of murdering his
mom whoa and
I'm reading between the lines a little
bit but you watch this and tell me what
you're getting out of this this is truly
bizarre stuff was
soel did we CLA check this one yeah
there was no oh nice thank you Zach
strange um like it it doesn't add up in
my head um you know she she fell off a
scooter not only she pass away when she
fell but she had a close
casket and that just to me just doesn't
add
up how how do you fall that
hard I think the Angels threw her down
and made sure she was not coming back or
that's not what Angels do man when since
when do F kill people I'm telling you
this is there's something really
up going on here what and made sure she
was not coming back or whatever I mean I
thought about this a thousand times she
might have passed out on the scooter no
it didn't really make a lot of sense I
don't know how high you need to fall to
have a closed casket but off a scooter
just doesn't seem high enough a scoter
have a terrible set of lungs like
a a moped like a a scooter let's get
details I'm depends like a if it's like
a vesa that kind of scooter no I think
he's talking about like a Mobility
Scooter Mobility Scooter yeah I was
picturing a bird scooter but I knew in
the timeline it didn't make sense cuz of
course you can die on a moped
I think yeah she was on a g like a not
even a Gatsby probably something even
less so she was running around with uh
his nephews on some little scooters she
fell off hers and hit her head oh that's
so horrible so we're talking like a
Razor scooter oh or that's what that
sounds like riding around with their
nephews yeah oh that's such a freak
accident
tragedy yeah but but this I don't
understand Romans well here let's let's
watch I mean it's crazy I don't
know how high you need to fall to have a
closed casket but off a scooter just
doesn't seem high enough now she did
have a terrible set of lungs I don't
know whether she would have made it
through anyhow um she had she had
conquered smoking yes she did and but it
had taken a toll on her she was hacking
for the rest of her Li it took a toll on
her also the the other weird thing was
the Christmas before she had a cough for
like six months or something yeah and I
remember Kurt coming to me he's like
make sure you know you iness whatever
like you guys really take care of toe
this
Christmas and that was her last
Christmas you already knew yeah yeah
I things just don't add up properly to
me there's too many weird it's almost
like you can see behind the scenes too
well there's too many weird things that
had to happen for her to pass the way
she
did and um
what so like what are you getting at
yeah and so that's the dad that's the
dad right that he's talking to later in
the interview the dad mentions these
Visions he had while the mother was
still alive and he said that in one of
them he was shown another woman not Sue
who he believed he was supposed to love
he then added that he is currently
remarried to this woman who was in that
Vision he got married to this woman only
two years after Sue died what the f is
going murderer I watched the full thing
for some more context I mean it's
definitely weird either way but he was
talking about they watch the movie
together as a family and at the end of
the movie the mother dies and he's just
talking about these weird coincidences
leaning up to it so he's saying more
like weird yeah Cosmic type more like
the Angel's body slammed his
mom's face into the Cur like a yeah like
a cosmic yeah you know slam yeah the
angel of death visited her what the hold
on I got to hear that
again but she had a closed casket by the
way you're her son ask someone you know
who put the funeral together ask someone
like you should be able to figure out
why is the casket closed who who managed
the funeral made that decision yeah
you're the dude probably with like the
money and the family I'd imagine you're
paying for it also isn't like deciding
to have a wake is like that's a decision
to see your dead family or friend to do
open yeah open casket is not usual is it
um it I've been to both you've been to
both depends yeah yeah yeah he has like
one brother and then it's the father and
him it had to be him or his wife that
managed that funeral exactly and why why
is he being like yo who decided to do a
closed casket
like I don't know man ask yourself
dude
I there's a lot of weird in the
those in Roman oods podcast I think if
someone just comb through all those
podcast they'd find some weird cuz
he like talks about hitting his kids
yeah that's what they got busted for
that recently where they were talking
about how that you got to people need to
start beating their kids again can you
find that that's what what I brought up
like a couple months ago but I didn't
really have anything prepared but
there's a lot of weird huh from
those you know what I'm seeing
even yeah did you notice any glaze on
that
family he's not glazed look at him he's
troubled well I'm reading that they are
Mormon oh dude I knew they were
religious cuz he said a angel body
slammed their face
yeah at least according to his
wikkipedia page it says he's member the
Church of Jesus Christ of Latter Day
Saints which is the Mormon Church oh my
God man they're very religious the
Mormons are having a hard
year hard year to be a Mormon oh here
here's an article I am Mormon actually
Roman Atwood says on popular podcast
with Logan Paul there you go let me hear
the dad again talk about
this and that just to me just doesn't
add
up how looks guilty look at his
face I feel like the called out right
now pushing you towards a certain
conclusion
here look at him how do you fall that
hard can you I'm sorry we need to pull
that that's like another great reaction
podcast clip how he just it's there um
Ian we got to pull this part
here how do you fall that
hard I think the Angels threw her down
and made sure she was not coming back
what Angels would do that that
is and he even did the
gesture that's crazy who would say such
a
thing holy
crap that's like unhinged man Angels
threw her down and made sure she was not
coming back that's a crazy Sound by
too the Angels they they knew she was
not coming back boom boom Spike that
that angel made sure her head be
Splat on the ground boy boom
touchdown God six
[Music]
points holy
man so they're Mormon huh according to
according to him in in an interview is
there something about beating your kids
that's Mormon
uh well probably not specifically Mormon
but I mean that's definitely kind of
like an old an old school oldy thing
it's kind of an old timey thing did you
find that clip I didn't I I'm not
familiar with it I'm looking though I
sure we watched that I'm seen a bunch of
like throwing my son off the balcony
blowing up my kid prank those I remember
watching I those ones are horrific too
send those we'll watch them as we look
yeah we definitely looked at them but
it's worth watching again let's go down
the Atwood pipe onine
from the Shetty pipeline to the Atwood
pipeline exploring a lot of pipes maybe
some people are not motivated by
growth growth I'm still fascinated by
where that accent comes from
uh um this and again he was a huge deal
to those of you who weren't around then
eight years ago 50 million views uh this
guy was like top prankster and when
pranksters were getting massive numbers
yeah Pranksters are like the
Minecrafters of yester year or something
or just the mainstream content I don't
know if that makes
sense yeah this one was
nuts I remember when he dropped this and
even for you today my girlfriend
believes that our three-year-old son and
I are looking at a used four-wheeler
she's going to come pick it up trck what
she doesn't know is that it's fully
remote control are you ready so so the
prank premise is he's want to goof his
wife into thinking his son died not just
died blew up that's so here it
[Music]
is he wait wait I would never ever ever
ever do that to ELA that's crazy why not
it's cuz you're not funny like that but
even being open to that idea
like G whiz
man
[Music]
and again probably not real that's it
you question the authenticity obvious
the girlfriend definitely in't on this
yeah
yeah but a million likes almost no
Downes people were just on board for
anything back
then that's the whole reason I started
making YouTube videos because I was
watching all these pranks and I was
losing my mind that nobody was calling
him out
for yeah look at this straight into
a
ramp what babe stop don't hey h oh my
God oh my God babe stop
no it's not funny I know that is not
funny it's it's kind of funny no it oh
no I'm sorry don't touch me I'm done I'm
done honey I'm I can't do it Kane right
there I cannot do it there's Kane um I
think she's acting probably still love
me
right but like again that's really not
funny that's like spousal abuse dude I'm
pretty sure but this is YouTube
eight years ago it was just crazy back
then
man I I was looking at YouTube and there
was all these guys Vitali yeah so flow
Mo and ET Roman atw they were
dominating YouTube and nobody was saying
anything about them prank inv let's not
lump them let's not lump them in with
all this well at the time they were
doing some wild you know they're
Geniuses in their own right I we've
grown to have admir them in different
ways we've we've you know got New
Perspectives on them yeah but holy to
moies man so I guess in a sense I do owe
my whole career today to these
pranksters in a way probably
right shout out
Roman um it's a prank
bro so that's
that we didn't find the beating the kids
one huh love same I did yeah you
did oh with his dad too from the same
podcast oh that's a that's an
action-packed podcast I could get you
couple loops but you would always catch
me you had it easy though my father used
a Bel on me yeah now you go to jail for
that no Brit's like I'm going to jail
did
uh excuse me
why I uh one time we had our
um my grandmother living at the house
and all of us kids were just torturing
her and making fun of her and she's
pretty much paraplegic kind of Jesus
man that's vicious
bro you were you were goofing on your
paraplegic
grandma what the this whole podcast
is
gnarly God and my mom said when your dad
gets home you're going to get it so all
day his kids are running around around
and uh making fun of you know oh yeah oh
yeah but when he got home he beat us all
with a
belt and we really had it coming too
such different times well now it's spare
the hand spoil the child not you know I
feel like
we're that's a big so the how you get
up
dysfunctional of kids that will tease a
paraplegic grandma is by beating them
yep there you go they go it's funny they
go I tell you what man I don't know what
to do but beat these kids every time I
beat them they do more up
my boy took a in Nanny's
bed Dre she a she liid in it all night
grandmother sitting by the bank of a
lack in society yeah like that
everything's so like sensitive it's
discipline that makes you great it
really is you watch all these greats
they've all been disciplined usually t
Ed and they become great who's what
great is he talking about I'd like to
know true our kids are going to be
great stop it's not funny what the
you're also combine beating your kids
with having a family blog dude it's
up when the camera goes off they
like what they're insinuating that they
beat them which is up they're
working kids and you beat them that's a
sounds there's a word for that
it's like it's like slave slavery I
don't know it's crazy not a nice thing
certainly not painting a nice picture no
make our kids great again you have to
lose everything to become great no you
don't have to this man just said make
our kids great again
yeah beaten but the discipline is
important yeah you're not great till you
lose everything and then yeah you seem
like you got I don't know anything about
this guy but this guy is giving like
total catastrophe of a
life I'm that that's that's my he made
himself great you know he said you're
not great until you lose everything and
you a't great his wife you ain't great
till or another Angel slam your wife's
face into the concrete boy he's
independently wealthy too from from
watching the I watched all the Vlogs and
I think he owns a factory or something
wait you've watched all these no or the
Vlogs back in the days I watch all of
them yeah so you were a fan of his big
fan yeah how old were you then you were
young yeah definitely 17 16 15 wow
yeah so his dad is Rich wealthy I don't
know how rich she is here okay
interesting realize that hey I can rise
above I can get higher than where I'm at
and then if you don't well that's it so
um what do you want to talk about I I
want this is this is why people say we
don't need another white guy with a
podcast thing it's
like this guy shouldn't be this guy
should not be in front of a microphone
for any reason is that hey like even he
you can even feel that he knows that as
well like I can get higher than where
I'm at and then if you don't well that's
it so um what do you want to talk about
I I want to I want to I want to bring up
that we it took many years on my first
YouTube channel to hit a 100,000 all
right whatever
anyway why were we talking about Roman
Outlet again
just the I'm sorry the meme that cam
yeah here's a replay of Roman's uh
mother taking a spill on
the I
me no that's literally what he described
man that doesn't seem like something an
angel would
do I thought they're supposed to protect
us this is a biblically accur dude jez
just I don't get why why Angel would do
something like that
man but there it
[Music]
is so that's that's uh the Atwood at a
boy Atwood at
awood you pick on a Sam's
Place yeah I just asked Sam the name of
it cuz I can't remember and the first
place is too far you guys wanted oh it's
too far haven't we ordered there yeah we
have but now they they cut us off I hate
that one probably cuz the freeway
collapsed cut them off um
anybody outside of I guess I got to work
quicker than usual so I I realized um
it's technically a holiday today really
yeah so that's kind of why I think it
was like somewhat okay today I think
it's going be way worse it's like uh
Veterans dayet Day right wait Veterans
Day that was Friday no that was Friday
that was oh was I think maybe some
places are celebrating it today I think
what happened Dan is that I got on to
the 10
after it collapsed and so there was like
no through traffic oh and I got on and
there's just not a lot of people on the
freeway mhm that makes sense it felt
like there was 10 million more cars on
my coming in this morning it was I mean
yeah if you coming from the wrong part
of town you've been they even
sent a warning message like a a panic
message to my phone yeah did they send
it to you at like 11:00 at night yes
real a lot of lot of competent people
working in LA to the government let me
tell you it did awake me from my Slumber
one of our major highways was I don't
know what happened there was a fire and
it like got there wasy there was
a giant um pallet storage yard
underneath a section of the freeway oh I
know exact oh my God yeah which seems
like a a great idea um you guys see the
photos and videos from it yeah yeah no
I'd like to brutal hold on let me send
one was anyone hurt before we watch it
look at this I don't I don't
holy so but uh the freeway was
hurt it's damaged to the extent that it
could be closed for uh months h on Earth
they said indefinitely close and this is
one of the main Motorway arteries in Los
Angeles yeah and it's just
closed jeez keep your hands off my
car
right well what do you want to do Jordan
I mean the freeway is on Fire
Man
like literally what do you what do you
expect them to do you know it's not fair
to put that
on on the
city the Angels did that somebody said
the angels's body slammed that
freeway made sure it never got up
again I wonder if there's going to be
like new laws of what you can keep under
the freeway cuz in my opinion it's so
crazy how they have like parking L and
truck stops under the highways like just
disaster waiting to Happ it's bad no
matter what but the uh the palet yard in
particular in retrospect like a very
good idea when we were making the 100
beanie challenge video we went to like
this Mass
beanie uh wholesaler and it was under
the 405 freeway yeah right and
it was I never see anything like that
you go in there and it's like you hear
everything you feel everything mhm it's
nuts um I didn't know that was a thing
Karen Bass the mayor says unfortunately
there's no reason to think that this is
going to be over in a couple of days we
cannot give an estimate right now
jeez so happy driving out there Los Los
Angeles Los
Angeles when I lived in Atlanta in 2017
there was a massive fire too that shut
down like a main Bridge so everywhere I
go there's just it's you yeah you're the
pro you did this I thought it was the
Angels it was the
Angels through him yeah they spoke to me
yeah um there's some great demilio
sister memes and again I know that well
they're older now like how old is how
old is Charlie now I mean I don't think
they're that young anymore she's n 19 oh
I was surprised by that too oh my
God she was really young before mhm
Dixie is 22 according to google well
anyway honestly I don't even blame them
for this somebody put this together and
I mean I don't know why influencers keep
doing this where they lar as like
minimum wage
workers um but I guess this was a
Walmart
collab here it is Walmart
collab no audio oh we have to mute it
okay so here I I'll narrate it
Walmart so they're I guess they're in
the Walmart break area have a good day
at work they
says and she said you too and they're
like huh us too we don't do this
and now they got oh
they're here they are with the chips and
they're working you see you show up
at work they're buying chips and look at
them it's so fun work at Walmart
I love working at Walmart I love
it um be happy snacks that's
the that's the brand that paid for this
what the is that it's like a
popcorn brand or something wait I think
it's theirs they're in every
video I think that's their brand oh wait
yeah cuz this happened a couple weeks
ago so it was a little hazy on it I
think you're right yeah they launched a
popcorn brand it's interesting
how there's like such a a Creator
economy for side businesses it's
interesting and the new one is like food
I've noticed I don't know if it's like a
beast inspired or prime inspired I guess
those cuz this one so big
mhm but like I don't I can't see this
being a good business like popcorn or
some well the I mean like the
energy drink people what do you call it
uh
is cleaning up doing all that stuff
they're probably seeing stuff like that
but I think get in on that the
beverage like the energy drink Market is
massive and people they grab multiple of
those a day right popcorn cat and CI
popcorn I mean how often you go to the
grocery stores and buy yourself a candy
cotton popcorn um I buy a normal almost
every time you do
mhm well here's a good video what the
happening here hold on I got to
start this over what is this okay he's
playing a part it said which flavor
represents you best I mean Jesus Christ
It's Just Popcorn all different flavors
flavor that's
yourself
um I
[Music]
think I feel like everyone wants me to
say cotton candy but I feel like nice
spice because I'm nice but I have an
attitude sometimes okay just but I know
everyone else is going to say that I'm
cotton candy I wanted her to say cotton
which I like her answer same it was
thoughtful we should try them let's see
what Dixie has to say I'll try it I
think the flavor but it's just
popcorn sounds yum there's a lot of
different popcorns May let's try it I
mean I don't know you think it's in our
grocery stores here I'll try it friend
of the show pokem man just released her
cookies today right I noticed that too
right so that's another I guess food
Goods is the vibe it looks super good no
cookies for you I would like to try
pokey's little
cookies you
know represents me is maple bacon cuz
I'm sweet and
salty I think the flavor that represents
me
is why do you care about which flavor
represents you what about how does it
taste I'm not trying to express myself
when I buy
popcorn like does it taste good does it
taste good
um I think
so
sometimes we have exciting news to share
run don't walk because be happy snacks
has finally hit the shelves of your
local Walmart store get ready to elevate
your snacking with a burst of flavor we
can't wait to hear which one is your
favorite
it's so interesting that you
know H they were just a normal family
and then she did a dance and now they're
doing this I mean what a what a
weird path in life yeah dude for being
the biggest like Tik Tock orever this
these ads are so horrible yeah I can't
like that's why I'm kind of surprised by
all this that it's so kind
of but if it maybe if it's their brand
they don't have like these handlers like
if you know Zara or someone pays you a
million dollars they're going to have
like producers and handlers and stuff I
don't know maybe they have like a bad
helper coming up with the all these
Boomer ass IDs oh she's still Mega
popping dude 20 million views holy
smokes this is
from this is from 29th wait she hasn't
posted in like two
weeks um but wow I cuz I always be
people being like oh she fell off who is
she
anymore uh no you're wrong she is still
it those are crazy
numbers
so good for
her be happy snacks give him a give him
a plug you got the cotton candy you got
the maple bacon you got the parmesan
garlic which flavor do you identify with
Olivia yeah what do you think which one
expresses your personality let me see
all the options again cotton candy maple
bacon parmesan garlic and nice
spice
um I know the answer but I'm so curious
to see what you say about I think
everybody wants me to say cotton candy
but I'm going to go with um cuz I know
I'm going to go with parm garlic that's
good choice and that is so you but now
let me ask you even a kind of an even
weirder question
which flavor do you think tastes the
best not I cotton candy but that is a
good question to ask anyway we love them
uh recognized by the state of Arkansas
but also the United States government
there's that now the downside of that is
extremely depressed so there's some
mental health issues that we bring to
the table I know you need a job man but
like this is not the way to obese I have
no references uh no work history no and
no education bro you don't have to say
all
that you know I want to say don't be too
hard on yourself but gez
Louise here was another one that of them
just like LARPing as minimum wage
employees I feel like this is a faux paw
that so many creators have made by now
that I'm surprised they they did
it you know yeah don't act poor that's
it don't just don't it's not it's not
when you work at Walmart it's not cute
and then you're like oh I'm look at me
I'm having so much fun here you guys you
guys get to do this every day this is so
much
fun I'm being paid like thousands of
dollars per hour for being here this
awesome so jealous of you
guys uh so not great Optics but I don't
blame them someone else's
fault
h big sock debate raging on Tik Tok I
feel actually I have a stake in this
this is exact
um difference between Millennials and
gen Z apparently this this lady has
detected a Surefire can tell the
difference between a millennial and a
gen Zed just by looking at their feet
are their socks up or are they wearing
hidden ankle socks because gen Zeds
exclusively wear their socks up and
Millennials still wear ankle socks
I'm a millennial okay let's first of all
you're wearing your socks up you're
wearing your socks up that's already
wrong no I no that's right that's what
she's saying you know what's funny is
that's right me and love both have our
socks up wait I thought you guys were
the disappearing socks people that's me
that's us oh okay that makes even less
sense then because I never ever I never
with the with the uh hi oh you do
Dan you know funny so Zach is showing
ankle socks he's gen Z so that goes
against the grain um you know I almost
always wear tall socks today was like
the one day that I wore ankle socks I I
guess I own both so I feel like a little
when I don't cover my ankles I
can't stand high socks I'll wear the
ankle socks when I wear like tennis
shoes but I I wear boots a lot and I
always have tall socks for boots so I
yeah sorry go ahead I I was just gonna
say that I always wear the ankle socks I
always wear short ones but I have long
ones because I get shaving in these
shoes so I always wear the short ones
and just make say any sense I'm confused
I'm not buying it I'm not buying it I'm
so confused about this now confused now
because I thought she was saying it
backwards cuz I never wear the the well
you're yeah you go against the gra oh I
I usually wear I mean until more recent
years look at you you got tube socks on
these are skims baby really are they
really oh my God congratulations wait
what what's what's a skim sock like uh
you know these ones are pretty basic but
they're there's like a this green and
black p i have that's a really good
quality I wanted something to go with my
slides and yeah but these ones are
pretty big they feel good cuz I'm always
looking for for good sock Brands it's
hard to find ones that I like I like the
ones that are like quart I call them
like a quarter socks they don't go up
like super high yeah Ela makes them the
they she's the one that makes my sock
she Ela makes my socks yeah
yeah
okay why
not thank
you um Dan bazaran cringe of the
week I've been stocking up a lot of good
Clips this guy is so
embarrassing like if anybody can watch
this H what is wrong with this guy
listen to
girls in a day and for like a
period it was like more was always
better four was better let me re I you
guys got to hear the beginning Dan's a
good man God damn it why did it open it
there just let me not mute it please and
I can't restarted either and D supposed
to we had an extension that added the uh
the like play controls to Instagram but
um they must have updated something and
it broke it okay here you got a immed
Med pause it I think that was a good
that worked out nine girls in a
day and for like a period it was like
more was always better four was better
and five was better and but when we got
to 30 where I'm like okay I'm on this
300t yacht I'm with you know 27
girls and it's like I'm miserable what
the I don't know man it's like that
deep seated feeling yeah it sounds like
a really fulfilling life Dude Killing it
out there I was on a yacht with 21 women
I them all but I was still sad
that there's like a lack and I think a
lot of people get caught up in pleasure
seeking I mean I was head on
into it this man it took him how long to
realize this like how old is Dan
bazarian like holy
dude his whole brand is like uh extreme
heian Hedonism isn't it I'm sorry
42 I just real one of the few people
that can actually now that I'm 42 I
realize doesn't make me
happy tell people you know that the
pleasure seeking isn't the
answer from a guy that's done it I think
they have a unique ability to then speak
to people about like okay you know I've
done all this it's fun don't get me
wrong but it's not the answer it's not I
don't even think Logan is
like Logan's got like a fiance you know
he's had meaningful relationships in his
life I used to have sex with my body
pillow bro
what okay interesting lead you to
happiness nobody in the world could have
convince me of what I've learned
myself right like like like somebody
could have told you all the
that you know and you're not going to
believe it you're not I'm the
type of I got to stick my
finger in that light socket I got to
shock myself I got to shock myself again
and again and again I'm about the fourth
time be like okay we've learned our
lesson but is it still hot you
know maybe not I don't know we'll see
but I'm just that guy so I did that I
don't think a lot of people get to the
end of the road you know and I went to
the end of the road with pleasure and so
I think I have a I took it all the way
baby what I took pleasure all you mean
he's trying to he's framing it in a nice
way you're a depraved
freak like you you are you are like a
soulless monster of a person dude you
sound unfulfilled it sounds like you
have not taken pleasure to the end of
the road exactly unique um ability to
understand that that's probably not the
answer it's probably not the
answer bro I nine girls
in a day and for like a period it was
like more was always better four was
better and five was better and but there
it is uh some daily meditations with Dan
bazarian let me read the comments I'm
curious what people say Paul thinks damn
my fiance was probably on that belt a
that's the top comment that's brutal no
Jesus CHR wait they're blaming the women
what's wrong with these women though to
accommodate like what the it's not
him you're not going to put the blame on
him silly woman I me do you think it's
really crazy to like bring a first of
all I doubt he's everyone on the
boat but do you think it's crazy for
like a 18-year-old to want to go on like
a mega yacht you know it sounds like a
fun weekend to me and have
everything paid
for or the adult who's
like well adult is really kind of a hard
label to put on Dan silly woman oh
here's a this is it inl the profanity
threw me off I had to unfollow I noticed
that too the account that posted this
clip is like an Uber
Christian oh what so yeah watch your
profanity Mighty Pursuit they don't like
the word h they don't mind
pre okay I'm not going to go there it's
just interesting where their tolerance
is for certain
things I'm going to hold my tongue today
we're having fun today let's keep the
Vibes
good my
Tong a close relationship with God is
what gives you real happiness I don't
think that's what Dan was talking about
unfortunately
but okay so many young men need to hear
this okay Dan is spread in the
gospel yeah I gather all the young
Christians here today to tell them that
I 29 in one day
Hallelujah and it didn't bring me any
closer to Jesus I was on a huge
yacht and I 9 10 11 of
them all day my my nut sack was empty
you guys empty I was shooting sawdust
out my dick at a certain
point like a
cartoon sand dust come out my di never
seen H and I'm here to spread this
inlighten message with y'all it doesn't
make you
happy never heard that before money
doesn't make you happy
amen this is the blood of God you know
what money doesn't make you happy
but does it is nice
you know what I
mean I feel when when people go I feel
like only a really really rich person
can say money doesn't make you
happy I think money absolutely makes you
happy yeah yeah money money is
does a
lot it can get you pretty damn
close uh
Menace there's probably everywhere right
yeah so I said the place but I'm opening
it Ian just be careful here all right
what are we
feeling what's the least noisy sandwich
would you
think the least noisy a one caprisi
capric is yeah not a lot of crunch capry
that's a good one yeah chicken pesto
capris they have that sounds good want
that what about that shimmy shy steak
and bacon
that sounds loud I'm not ready for bacon
at this hour bacon like really slows you
down some days are are these the ones we
had at the live show yeah yeah yeah yeah
yes do you want
that don't call him a fat pig you can't
do I'm looking for a health health is
one which one's got lots of veggies in
it Italian Roast Beef doesn't look half
bad
vegan Bon me dude it's the way to go
that's what I'm getting yeah that Bon Me
did look pretty good I like the spread
on that let me let me get the
um let me get that Italian Roast Beef
okay you know what I'm saying just
normal and we roast that chicken Capra
is which one has more calories I already
hit add to cart bro hold on
Italian Roast Beef has 62 that's
actually pretty good the chicken pest
has 600
interesting you would think the chicken
pesto might be heavier maybe it's a
bread
thing what do you think about that bread
com dude the oh wait no they
roll oh no they list the bread
separately the 620 on a Toasted
Roll 300 so it's
920 okay that's pretty that's a lot
chicken pesto has eight
60 and in the RO which is also a lot
Jesus that
LE it's tough out here when you count
calories G whiz
man all right just get me the
um let me get that chicken pesto CPR
it's got less calories recognized by the
state of Arkansas but also the United
States government there's that no the
downside of that is I am extremely
depressed so there mental health issues
that we bring to the table and then
physically I I am morbidly obese I have
no references uh no work history buy no
education
mhm keep going this and when you my this
is my favorite part you might see rumors
that I beat my
ex-wife and go on Fon okay
what's the
new what about the one where he says and
it might be a
pedophile how old is
it you didn't want that one Zach
aggravated assault how old is
it um thought it was in there
okay POV you find out you're adopted oh
God not this guy we've talked about him
this guy is
really really something
I love this um he his name is
Lewis
Sanderson is so good
38 and he just reenacts like horrific
tragedies and just really commits he's
the Daniel de Lewis of Tik Tok you might
say this man is a committed actor so
here he found out he's adopted at 38 my
whole life has been lie and I guess he's
presenting it like it's
real I
a he he says hello Mom hello
Mom I know I
know my whole life's been a
lie I mean not really he's crushing this
dude I adop I know I'm adopted it's
really
raw
you can why didn't you tell
me my my whole life's been
[Music]
aive no dude oh the slowmo oh that hits
oh he's about to
explode
whoa wait oh I'm telling you cast
him today in your student
film yeah ER and Eric Roberts C your
feature film I just I find his Focus so
interesting here's a one where his kid
dies I mean why would you lar that this
is the guy that Dr his own kid in the
pool too yeah watch that Tik Tok has 59
million in in collaboration with Roman
Atwood dad Falls from Cliff during hike
with sun you are
we haven't uh checked this one so it
might be uh it's probably oh yeah it has
a song on it so he's walking with his
son he's so cute and sweet I hate to
even think about like why why are we
even putting the situation on him look
at
this daddy that kid looks like he's so
sweet Josh I need you to stay
there Josh
sorry
I love you son what the
daddy that baby couldn't give less of a
yeah that kid is like
whatever that kid cannot act yeah for
daddy
garbage oh man Daddy he fell dude that
doesn't look that that painful that drop
looked pretty short well that was a
pretty low effort one and this one got a
lot of views
Tik Tok pays you more now if you have a
minute long video and I noticed that all
these are a minute long exactly and a
lot of slow-mo shots in right really
stretching it out do we know what's the
revenue like on the M minute ones like
is it comparable to YouTube or is it
still like dooo I don't think it's
comparable to YouTube but I'm not
certainly well I wish I did but Tik Tok
is just ignoring us we cannot get our
account monetized we have should I say
it you could say it yeah we have like we
have we've had three reps during like a
couple
during the year I've had like active
conversation with them they've helped me
with stuff and just now all of a sudden
they stop talking to us they just
ghosted us that's like every Rel that's
every professional relationship
in my life it's so bizarre and they're
also because I made the Tik Tok account
in Sweden they refused to they're it's a
Swedish account you can't get monetized
in America it's like we're in America
man anyway here's another I'll watch one
oh this is the one where his kid drowned
that's so crazy here I'm not gonna watch
that one this one is his his beautiful
daughter dead geez
[Music]
dude where are these
extras he broke through he's
running he found the daughter dead man
they're roping it
off wish you would at least get like a
higher frame
R video for the
slowo security please let me see my
daughter he
crashes security guards in this rural
Bridge you can't go in there Kelly is
that my daughter in
there we got to hear him though well
then open it
up
[Music]
someone hire him just give him a job so
he can stop doing
this and he can stop torturing his
friends by making them be a part of
these skits spitting all
over I'm not kidding you every video is
like this here he has his dad died
somebody help
me oh I got to hear the sound though
stop putting music under this dude
go
ahead oh nice disclaimer oh go ahead
look I mean dude okay all right I mean
what the look at nobody doesn't
like him
folks God damn it J all right oh God we
could uh go through something prepare
him for next time yeah it's all right
we've looked at him
before see what uh you just
trapped what a clip of me looking
watching it well he he maybe the CRA Tik
Tok yeah I didn't know that yeah oh
I don't is this is even one of our
accounts is it a podcast daily
Clips our that's our boy but this is
that's not the channel so this is Lewis
Anderson which I think is his name this
is the new one that's the fan channel oh
okay fan Channel got it he's probably
monetized and we're not he probably did
dude if anyone from Tik Tok just reach
out to us please like it's so
we had like active conversation with
them and then I don't know I've ever
seen it's stunning yeah no children were
harmed in the making of this
video never leave a child or did you
respond to it right oh my God man why
would he do that this one is
definitely so he just posted my
clip another one how
many oh okay okay shout out Lewis keep
up the good work
brother he's like you know you know how
Gary ve was like imagine somebody
shooting the person you love most in the
world genuinely sit there for five
minutes pretend one of them got shot in
the face he goes and he pretends that
his son drowned every day he even
reenacts it so he can be
appreciative about the the good times he
probably feels so good about it just I
love you son you're not
round it's really wholesome uh let's see
we got the do stuff we got the dream
song contest winners let's do the dri
stuff oh my God the document the
documentary Wars Jimmy Lee Wars is
heating
up um there is now a a growing feud
between the two Jimmy Lee documentarians
documentarians and Jimmy is putting out
St statements I which I've never seen
him do
before it is so
interesting
um Jimmy is embroiled in his first
internet drama I think which is really
you know he's a
star he's a
star so um let's do the do one before we
get too too to deep in because
everyone's waiting for that I'm going to
go to the bathroom real fast though and
I'll be right back thank you
okay I can't wait for this Bond meme man
I'm thinking about it I'm thinking about
it a lot
sh I'm
hungry what' you get I got the
steak and bake of course he did you
kidding huh you do anything uh with your
p p this weekend I brought him to a
football game or no B Jesus Christ
basketball game with the with some of
the crew here love the time love the
time
how was that you basketball fan now no I
it's a good time with friends and when
the team ons wins that's a good time I
don't know how that feels like I thought
the Clippers lost they lost they did
lose yeah to the worst team in the
league too
[Music]
nice not the worst team in the league
anymore yep still
are
right standings wise apparently it was
James Martin's first game in every time
he didn't e Sam and I would go H James
James Harden oh what' I say James Martin
oh James Martin J Martin probably would
have played
better wait is he on the Clippers now
yeah oh what the when did that
happen this year yeah yeah yesterday was
the first game couple weeks ago oh
Are you happy about that Ian Ian's a big
CL I'm not going to subject anyone to
basketball talk this channel I don't
think it's the audience the audience
doesn't know but Ian is
very I will say we brought we brought
hawk in too and oh yeah right uh he was
he was stoked yeah he he loved it he was
he was telling me about it he had a good
good time yeah yeah good guy great guy
go
[Music]
Celtics go Celtics okay got it so I
that's the only Sports Talk we got to
talk about somebody says that the way we
pronounce the name of the Vietnamese
sandwich is a setting them what's the
right way to say that what' you call it
I said Bond me it's me that's right
that's the correct way I apparently not
bunme bunme
pronunciation let's hear
it we are looking at how to pronounce
these
names do
sound from
Vietnamese so make sure to stay tuned to
the channel how do you say it on
me what is this video it's also what you
said there was like 20 seconds of intro
hold on let's listen we are looking at
how to pronounce this name as well as
how to say more interesting both and
confusing names from Vietnamese cuisine
so make sure to stay tuned to the
channel how do you say it B me this guy
said it the same way I did and he
clearly knows what he's talking about
so's hitting that brown note frequency
man Jesus Christ it's gorgeous gorgeous
voice all right let's do the dubri
dubrick let's do the
[Music]
dud so let's see another person has come
forward Analise Marie who's a popular
twitch streamer do you know if do you
know who that is no I do not maybe by F
if I see their face what was the name uh
Analise Jr
Marie I I linked her Instagram in there
oh okay let me see it's pretty big do
you recognize her in the Vlogs cuz I
don't I don't recogniz her I recognized
her ex-boyfriend who was in the Vlog
Squad his name was Joe his Instagram's
also in there if you want gotcha so okay
so this is her and then here's Joe I
guess this was her significant
other I don't remember this guy who is
wait which one is this guy it's uh the
white
hat I just saw him on the demilio page
right this guy Joe okay oh oh they're
all they're still together they still
hang out go to
Joe they broke up into little groups it
seems and it's nice to see them all
doing really well without David for
example this one post has 200 likes so
and four
comments not to be uh harsh but you
David put these people to through so
much with the hopes of his Fame rubbing
off on them
and it it surprises even me how little
people care about all the satellite
characters in his world like even Jason
Nash is kind of struggling to get he's
doing NPC streams D yeah great I don't I
think even he's struggling to get like
moderate
views what is he let's see last time we
checked he was doing that like all day
every day is he live yeah he's live
right now no he's not up no he is
not making for money right now poor man
please he's in that same kitchen hold it
looks like he's uh he's away right now
but I see the kitchen there he
is there he
is is it double the audio
double I think it's playing tce how many
people are watching right now we're
going to put that on merch off
good in only four words you're a good
writer angel I would suggest that you
get into writing 29 295 Jason man that's
too sad I'm turn that off it is no I
want to keep
watching because Jason was if anyone
been well actually Karina probably
Karina Karina crushed it as far as
anyone else in that Vlog she seems way
more
shrewd
uh did was anyone else successful out
that grou Jeff yeah Jeff oh you know
what Jeff made it because he
left right big Nick is crushing it I
guess you could say Zay and Heath they
have a podcast do people watch it yeah
okay they have like famous guest us from
the so that see yeah he's doing great
pull up that Jason I got to see that
again I need to understand what do has
wrought on this world
he's on Tik Tok begging for money that's
sad well he's just kind of kicking it it
seems like I don't know if he's begging
for money why is he live all day every
day no he's doing the like game thing he
basically competition thing all right
who's going to give me the most money
that's the game can you pull it up Dan
yeah I'm pulling it up right now that's
the game let's see freaking go back to
basics you know what I
mean
no this is for Earl Gray out in London
guys from the United States to London D
do something to help your friend let
just do it we've got a minute left
and and he's playing copyright music we
have a minute
left he's playing copyright music yeah
yeah yeah I got you slip inside the eye
of your
mind all right so anyway oh Isis about
them in a live stream in
2021 Analise revealed that a member of
the Vlog Squad was very drunk and
stepped on her foot in May
2018 and shattered
it uh causing
lifelong condition oh she says that she
was told to keep the incident a secret
H sounds
familiar so wait her telling her stories
claimed why got claimed the uh the audio
and I tried to remove it but it it it's
too low quality of a video to remove the
audio is it music yes it's
music H not even my friends knew until I
oh weird it's so quiet yeah so maybe
I'll do CC you have CC that'd be
great uh the initial one may
have it's highlighted but I can't click
it oh here on no I don't have an
option
okay yeah send me the original one it
probably has the Clos
captions so um since 2018 Analise has
been open About Her diagnosis with
both
limb F fima Li
feda and may Turner syndrome
under social media on various sites
matern syndrome is a condition that can
increase the risk of deep vein
thrombosis a lifethreatening blood clot
usually in the leg analy said that she
has also been diagnosed with lymp feda a
long-term condition that causes swelling
in the body's tissue and she's she's
saying that whatever happened with the
Vlog Squad whatever injury she
sustained cause these conditions right
mhm that's
crazy how many okay
here Wait So how what how's this helpful
it's that's just where I got it from is
there there's no YouTube Source
oh
so is it on
YouTube we were looking for it earlier
here let me look
again
hold on one
[Music]
sec uh well her st stop with the side
camera
man we're not over we're not
overcompensating here we we have one
camera and that's it no no no
no all right so what well we're going to
going to transcribe
it and uh we'll read it back but
essentially oh there's an article here
let's read
this so this came
out in 2021 but we hadn't heard about
her she was kept a
secret she says a member in his Vlog
Squad got drunk and broke her foot and
it caused a chronic
illness in a live stream she said a
chronic illness was caused by Vlog Squad
members she said the person was very
drunked and stepped on her break how do
you how that story doesn't make sense to
me I believe her but I I wonder if she's
covering because how do you step and
shatter somebody's
foot right it doesn't really make sense
and cause like lifelong
damage right very drunk I mean he'd have
to like stomp hard on her foot or
something seriously and an angel body
Ang god her
um let's see during a live stream
someone in the Vlog while I was drunk
and an idiot and they're the reason why
I have my chronic illness she said they
were drunk they were being an idiot they
stepped on me twice stepped on my foot
so did they really it must have been for
David yeah like hey dude stomp on her
ankle bro don't know when ex do it again
do it again stop on ankle you guys she's
passed
out the Vlog Squad is a YouTube
Collective yada yada after allegations
came to light Dober faced oh now they're
talking about uh
Dom since
2018 Marie has been open About Her
diagnosis of both lymph what is Li how
do you can we get that pronunciation guy
again uh hold on oh okay it seems like a
word also they spelled it wrong okay so
that's what what okay that doesn't help
me either lymphadema lyma lymphadema
it's easier than it looks yeah
lymphadema
uh Insider y'all don't have spell check
and may therer
syndrome Mayer syndrome is it sounds
like pretty rough those and this is a a
DEA noodles
repost not even although this is from
2001 I guess that when death was
not he
wasn't there was people watching right
like that have we everal have we talked
about de noodles
since I I've never seen um such
a complete and
utter dispersion of somebody's audience
it feels like overnight he went from
having like a genuine YouTube channel
with like 100,000 views per vid to
having like a hundred or I I've never
seen anything like that how did that I
knew he got into like some kind of
Dramas and beefs and did and said dumb
things
but
wow uh she said that Joe did nothing
wrong but added that she sometimes feels
that she wouldn't be in this position if
she didn't know Joe uhoh Joe there
something I'm working on with my
therapist she said I know it's an
accident but still triggers me because I
had to keep it all
inside she tweeted out as time goes on
sometimes people need to grow separately
on their own Joe and I broke up a few
months ago and have nothing but love for
each other okay they broke up she
reveals that
um
oh in the July 13th
Vlog um entitled surprising my little
brother with Tupac she said said I'm
vulnerable I had the worst four days of
my life everything flipped on my head
meanwhile they're like don't say what
happened keep it a secret this is Jake
and he made this Iron Man glove this is
real and he's how do you get the balls
to do that to continually tell people
that are
like lifelong
injuries to everyone's getting maimed
around you at all all the time very
suspicious not even my friends knew
until I told them the reason because I
was told to keep this a secret for many
years and basically it just got to a
point and I couldn't handle it any
longer and Joe did nothing wrong
basically the short version is comes
down to someone in the Vlog Squad was
drunk and an
idiot and is the reason I have my
chronic illness
today they were drunk and idiot and
stepped on me stepped on me twice and
broke my
foot that sounds hor
horrible drunk David is like breaking
people like this isn't the first time
I've heard someone say not even close
like I was I was told to keep it silent
and it ruined me it ruined me
until I had no
choice um dude you're right about the
stepping thing there's no way there has
to be something she's not saying her it
sounds like her foot was like
wait you don't think that that would be
enough to her foot if somebody was
like forcefully stomping on her foot as
hard as they could yeah but who would do
that right probably she said they were
drunk they probably just didn't
intentionally do it but just acting like
idiots no he did it twice it sounds
intentional well seems very weird well
that com combined with the chronic
illness probably what made it so bad it
might have not have been as hard I'm not
sure well she it sounds like the chronic
illness was a result of the injury the
article I don't know I unless I'm
missing something it didn't seem clear
to me on if it she had it prior no no
it's clear oh
okay it clearly said right that yeah she
says it comes down to someone in the
Vlog S I was drunk and an idiot and they
are the reason I have my chronic illness
oh okay yeah want to make sure
um so it seems like he's had a really
good exchange with people you get
lifelong trauma and chronic illness and
in
return I get a lot of use you for money
and Views it's a healthy exchange of
goods and
services made it on his own and it
actually works look at it let's see it
all right three two hand down hold
[Applause]
it oh
God a l easier these videos like looking
back in retrospect you can see the so
debaucherous it's just so wrong
all right guys I'm here with vardon he's
taking I mean we knew knew it like how
they laugh at everything over the top
and everything is just
like Scientology is plays skateboarding
today he's going to try to drop in dude
every time a fat kid drops
in two one push oh there we go my God
painful that looks hella painful
his and that's a child that's far D yeah
wait why did you guys do that to
him wait why are you guys bullying him
wait look at this that was
[Music]
brutal I thought maybe it won't be that
bad his ankle I thought maybe it
won't be that he get the camera in his
face it's like damn you ain't bro
that's a gnarly fall that looks really
painful he did the splits I know that
man can't do the splits hell no by
choice choice he just stumbling upon oh
my God oh my are you good stop laughing
stop laughing are you good yeah I'm good
are you sure get up and walk it up get
up and walk it up shut the up you
fat so that was pretty good that was
pretty good I'm emotional they're forced
to play along you know with the camera
in their face and the whole the whole
point of this is to make a great video
and everybody wants to be a team player
so nobody's going to be like dude I'm
up like you get out of my
face or well if they did they would just
make that seem like a joke too probably
right now I am vulnerable you have no
idea yeah I had the worst four days of
my life everything flipped on my head
okay oh he said that when she dumped
him hasn't had a good week so Jo his
girlfriend's foot got
demolished
cool Good Vibes
[Applause]
only Good Vibes only at the do compound
bunch of friends having fun together
vlogging it we're just living living
life we're just a bunch of Carefree fun
loving people we're just having great
times living Our Lives Ming our friends
permanently oh yeah uh awarding women on
the weekend yeah not a we just like to
get out and do stuff doing our thing
dude we're just out here doing our thing
we're literally
Carefree how can you be more Carefree
than than literally mamming your friends
on a weekly basis
there it
is thank you for transcribing that
Olivia of course of
course uh
meanwhile let's bring the Vibes up a
little bit this
guy oh I love this was my favorite man I
love this
one this guy is like
Prince he's on another
level head go my heart
I listen to it on drive you did I've
been listening to it
too he's crazy
[Music]
talented so anyway a really sweet uh
followup he posted his reaction to
Instagram it was very nice here it is
Ela saying that she likes the
picture and them saying that they want
to see me perform live I could burst
into
tears cuz
like I put so much effort into loads of
music that I do and to get like a kind
of response like that from people that I
watch every day literally like the
podcast is on and it helps me get to
sleep and stuff and I've been following
it for years to get a kind of response
like that sleep
no dude you're missing the point he lets
it run all night oh that is good for
watch time watch time like crazy I'm
like so
overwhelmed I love
cardo oh I love you card I'm sorry you
lost I see he wrote oh my God this is so
lovely I'm so massively
overwhelmed I love you man you are
freaking such a talent I want to hear
more of his music actually there's
me too but in the meantime we actually
have the two winners uh lined up vampir
Vampira XOXO and the Jersey Lawman the
mysterious Jersey
lawmen so I wanted to basically
congratulate them and um say thank you
and just to give them a shout out are
they are they ready uh the law man is in
the lobby bring the law man in so I got
to know who the this bring on right
now stand
by this is his song man we'll have your
little devil after that
my this your wake up song I this is what
I put on in the morning I was getting
ready
Al oh here we
go oh my God the face revealed oh my God
so it was you doing the face your face
let me get a look at and uh and the ha
as well all right let me get a look at
you okay I can switch over here so oh
you are you you're English eh I am I'm
I'm a I'm a Brit whoa and how is that
for you to tune into the show is it
difficult um no I normally watch that
late anyway so it's it's it's good for
me right so what's the story why do you
have so many talents I don't
understand um I don't know I started
video editing um just like watching
montage paraders and stuff back in of
your EXE videos yeah um and then I just
like had to do it for work a B I do like
web design and stuff so I just carried
on learning it and then um I don't know
I've just been doing music for a few
years so I just sort of I don't know I
just I like making content geez dude and
you shred on the
guitar yeah can we see I don't even can
you can you just can you shred something
Zack Z to see it to believe it it
probably wouldn't come through but um I
can show it it's real there there's one
we see a
guitar that looks nice
nice yeah I can uh I can record um a
real me playing the solo for Instagram I
actually just want to see that unrelated
to needing
receipts uh what's your name by the way
I don't think I caught it uh I'm Felix
Felix Felix nice to meet you man big fan
over here dude we are Dan is kind of
discovered you or at least he put you on
my radar yeah I don't know if I was the
first to stumble across the cter if one
of these guys showed me but uh but as
I've said on the show I I didn't follow
the the Jersey Outlaw I just follow the
law
man so what yeah um what made
you how what brought you to making the
the Jersey law man can you explain the
lore
there um I just trying to so provide
some balance because you know Jimmy
sometimes goes a bit far so I thought
I'd reel him back in a bit basically
Ah that's nice the
yingyang two parts of the same
mind he um he he messaged me recently
saying he's coming to London and he
wants to meet up with me um so I'm I'm
thinking about going to see him and I I
was like I was thinking about like going
up dressed as him or something and then
I I heard recently that it's a family
vacation so he's going to be with his
wife and kids and
I didn't think to tell me that before
the out reach Jimmy does will never stop
surprising me um he is a man of the
people say what you will about him but
uh that's very nice well dude you're
like a mega talent I don't know what to
say that whole video was nuts and how
did you create the Oliver the Oliver
tree part was that all
AI uh so basically I I put a green
screen behind me and then had this
jacket on and then this wig and I just
lip synced it and then I just um used
some AI thing to just put his face over
mine and then put some effects on it it
thank you thank you and then but you
also ran a filter on the voice too right
to sound like him yeah basically um Gad
of his songs took the vocals out and
then like trained an AI on it then and
then I had to sing it and then apply
that to it and do a little of autotune
and stuff yeah that's incredible man I'm
I'm working on getting dream uh that
collab
man um he's not he's not answering my uh
text
is that he's not there he he's not there
he's not there he's not there he's not
there well he did say he did
say that he was
interested in doing an official remix
okay I mean that's something if it
involves so so I don't know I mean how
could he say no to these yeah yeah he's
got to do it he's got to he's got it and
what's your is your ambition in life are
you trying to be a musician or or are
you trying to make content is there
something like what do you is there
something you're working for or is this
all just for
fun um it's kind of for fun but um I've
been I've been making music for a while
but I haven't really released much of it
but I might I might um I I might start
putting a bit more out but um yeah I
don't I just do it for fun mainly though
I just I just I just get an idea and
then I still have to make it so I just
put it up on the Instagram right damn
how old are you can I ask uh I'm
23 I wish I had your skills at that age
and you have like a you have like a
you're like gamefully employed too right
you said you got like a real job uh well
I do like freelance web design so
the law man has got it all going
on dude he's got a uh um Primus uh
forgive me there is AI in it right uh
there's a yeah yeah um I mean it's
wicked good like he does his Primus
parody song and it's oh yeah I remember
that that blew my mind yeah it was
yeah yeah that's um that's an AI I've
got two AIS of Jimmy I've got one I
trained on him speaking and one on him
singing and then that's that's a Jimmy
singing a prim that's so good that's so
awesome well
um I it's nice to meet you I I didn't
know what to expect uh I didn't know if
you were a real person or or I was
partially expecting another AI
representative to come on the screen but
here he is uh he's the real deal real
deal nice to meet you
Mega I'll let you know if I um if I meet
up with Jimmy you'll probably see some
video of that but um he doesn't ring me
as well which is funny because I thought
he ring me all the
time give you said ring he wanted to
ring
you yeah he I've spoken to him once on
the phone but I don't think he knows it
the same person because I was like I was
doing I was like reding his website at
one point but he didn't want to end up
finishing it but he just the first 20
minutes was him just rambling jokes to
me and I had no idea what he was talking
about so I
just be careful because you've seen what
it's done to Zach sharing the number
it's taken a toll on Zach yeah just be
be cautious man I bet yeah I'll try but
I'll tell you this if you have any ideas
or stuff like you are such a mega Talent
you want to do something for the show or
you have any ideas reach out to us keep
a line of communication open okay yeah
cool thank you I'll have a thing I like
I like I like what you got going on over
there Felix I'd love to jam with you
sometime dude if you're ever out here
you're a wicked player man hell yeah
there you go thank you yeah that'd be
awesome bro you got to put put out a
video of you shredding I have to see it
okay I'll do it I'll do it is that your
main instrument the guitar do you play
anything else um yeah mainly the guitar
I got a bass recently but just sort of
learn that a bit and then I like I well
I I don't really play the piano but I
like play a little bit of it um
but yeah mainly the guitar that's why
I've been playing most nice yeah
dude um well thank you so much get uh
the guys will get your did you guys get
his info for the the grand
prize uh I bought oh we got it okay Co
yeah we got it yeah you can DM me yeah
thank you man thank you for sending all
the great memes all the great memories
and uh absolutely love everything you do
so cheers man yeah thank you you'll see
some more for me in the future all right
I'm tuned in I'm tuned in I'm watching
the law
man shall go on even if even
after even after Jimmy Lee is gone the
law man for what I'm not saying like
dead but I mean he is old he's getting
up there I mean he's a lot older than he
is yeah he's like he's like 48 49 now
but the law man will continue damn that
dude
he that dude is a mega Talent all right
we got Vampiro on talk about Mega Talent
yes indeed one second we get her set
up yeah uh connecting audio okay she
should hear us now hello
hello it's a little quiet oh it's really
quiet your mic turn it up a little bit
zachi might be us so let's see if we can
turn it
up say something
now hi there we go there you are
hello
first of all congratulations you are
amazing uh
everybody
has uh fallen in love with uh the the
song you made the audience was going
crazy for it are you yeah go
ahead oh I was just saying thank you I'm
so happy to be here so good to talk to
you Ethan yay thank you all that's nice
thank you it's awesome I just love
seeing all the talent in the audience
but so tell me about the are you
actively making music what's the story
there yeah I actively make music I've
been doing it ever since I was
14 um I am self-taught so I'm still
progressing in my music production in
mixing it's all self-taught so I'm
learning each and every time I do a
music
project um but
yeah I I do want to do music fulltime I
just keep progressing in that
and yeah so are you um do you play
instruments or was it is it a produced
on the uh the computer like what's your
process or do you work with other
musicians um so I use logic pro X um I
do it all on the computer um but I'm
selftaught on the piano and guitar as
well amazing that's
amazing I think you're um I think you're
really on to something the everything
that you did was really good it really
stood out what where where can we find
more of your stuff I want to look at
it well um I have a
SoundCloud um I just posted that on my
Ig page it has a bunch of my my previous
work um it's all again I'm so amateur at
all of this um but eventually I will be
producing a lot more high quality music
so I'm excited for that especially since
I want to do music full-time I think the
whole idea of Vampira is just so fun I
want to build lore with that Alter Ego
so I'm like excited to get into that
here is uh vampir XOXO on Instagram is
this this is the best place for people
to follow you would you say or yeah cool
I'm most active there nice um slay uh I
pinned the SoundCloud Link in the uh in
the chat as well if people want to find
that and the production on the song
sounded phenomenal yeah I'm you're all
selftaught cuz I thought the mixing it
sounded very professional very clean it
was so challenging I I my vocals were so
loud I've never mixed my vocals that
loud before it's all such a big learning
process for me um so I'm surprised I
finished the song within a week right
when you guys made the announcement I
was like all right I'm I'm just gonna
stop the stream right now I'm gonna go
and work
on I'm glad we we pushed more time
because I knew yeah it was definitely
worth it a long time it takes a long
time
dude I thought should I listen do you
want me to listen to this one I don't
know some people don't like like to play
their old music is there a song here you
want me to listen to that you think
particularly Yes actually um so I did a
mashup of two of grimes's songs it's
called be a body I love Grimes oh you
know what play it if it
has Grim in it it does it use her like
music
no I did everything it's all different
okay cool oh my god I think I'm pretty
positive when we were listening I was
like this sounds like Grimes like I it
like influenced my Grimes a little bit
wait where uh how do I find I'm so
Boomer she's a massive inspiration for
me I think it's Ash ni Melanie Martinez
and um an
Grimes my inspiration it's this one here
be be a body yes okay all right let's
hear it
[Music]
oh is it uploaded to disc disco Dro kid
or anything like that no just on YouTube
um and SoundCloud cool so you're you're
good you're good
[Music]
yeah
my CU I
[Music]
want
the audience loves you Vampiro they love
Vampiro all of you oh my God your voice
is crazy good you have a beautiful
voice you um right now
now I'm struggling with my voice right
now just because um okay I live in
Arizona and I'm highly allergic to the
atmosphere in Arizona right from
Arizona and so that takes a toll on my
voice and I'm also like highly allergic
to my cats and I have three of them oh
God so right now I am struggling like it
this is probably a little bit
embarrassing but it takes me hours upon
hours to record one song and why is that
CU you can't get the vocals right
correct I heavily rely on autotune
that's my biggest secret no I don't
think I can tell the difference between
a sound great exactly you know what I
mean whatever you're doing is working
don't don't sell yourself short
absolutely well yeah well I am very
excited to to follow along and I think a
lot of people are as well at home I
encourage everybody to go on the Vampira
Journey Vampira XOXO and well the link
to her SoundCloud is on that page so
probably just go and uh thre it in the
description of the episode as well
Arizona I Heard lots of gators out there
any Gators out there Bunch oh yeah
definitely it's still an issue still an
issue um well
oh you know the whole little devil thing
that was that wasn't serious just are
serious I love that okay all right I
really do I just threw that out there
you know I just being a little bit
silly okay thing I love it vampir your
fans we should be called Little Devils
yeah are you kidding Little Devils done
Little
Devils that's the fan base hi Vampira
I'm a little devil I'm a little devil
too damn
I absolutely in in in so I just want to
say thank you so much and
congratulations you're so talented I
just hope wish the best for you and I
think a lot of people are going to be
following along now so keep
slaying thanks and I just want to put in
my two cents about how much I love you
guys I know a lot of people do this
please no lay it on thick yeah lay it on
thick I need it right now I love you
guys so much and actually
followed H3 ever since you guys
started at the time I I actually lived
in Jerusalem really yeah um oh wow par
are diplomats so I've traveled all my
life whoa yeah and so um at the time I
was just in Middle School browsing on
YouTube and I kept seeing uh videos of
you with Ela and at the time I didn't
understand understand what I was
watching but I definitely started
catching to the age3 uh fandom uh once I
left Jerusalem so um I've I've known you
guys for forever ever since you started
and I love well and thank you for saying
that again just because so many people
want to call me a Zionist this is
another person that left
Israel and then I will say I don't want
to say because of me but it sounds like
you know something clicked when you left
Israel right right that uh you know so
I'm just
saying I'm an antiz mostly that um
diplomats they have like a certain
amount of time um on their post I was
only there for three years so that's
essentially that but I loved my
experience in Jerusalem and um I I wish
I could go back again I used to live
right next to the old city like 5
minutes away well that's that's such an
intense part of town there's just so
much hustle and bustle it's like such a
city city you know what I mean loved it
my sister and I I was like 12 at the
time and she was like 10 her and I would
just com around Jerusalem by ourselves
go to rebar or like get I I just like
buy things just cute little girly things
right
I don't think I don't think people
realize like I didn't for sure when I
first went to Jerusalem like it's such
a it's such a like uh booming City it's
not like just Oldtown although Oldtown
is
pretty pretty wild but there's so much
going on there it's pretty amazing Town
it really is yeah I I mean I'm fled and
lucky that my family and I experienced
such we had such a good experience in
Jerusalem
mhm and I I mean at the time I didn't
really understand the conflict um now
I'm more aware of it um but yeah um I I
just wanted to throw that out there
thank you that's so nice I'm so grateful
thank you I'm so grateful I'm happy that
our our paths uh crossed and that
um that will continue on and you know
I'm I'm excited so thank you you on the
dream Alum I know I'm working on the
collab it's going to happen I'm I don't
know that much about dream but don't
look into it too much maybe not right
now don't don't look into it too much
the less you know the better yeah Little
Devils forever though
Devils love
it thank you so much nice to meet you
bye there it is there it is
congratulations and we got their uh
payment stuff both of them good I'm in
touch with both of them Olivia will
gather it all together thank you thank
you beautiful wonderful
folks I I got to I feel like I got to
talk to cardo too or at least just give
him a shout out you can just send him a
a DM just let him know that how much you
loved is he on Instagram do you want me
to send the zoom link and see if we get
lucky H we can move on
I guess yes send him the link I guess
and maybe okay we'll continue on but if
he answers I just want to glaze him up a
little
bit you
know uh because I you know I
mean and his video was very
sweet but yeah follow everybody I think
vampir has got quite a little following
here in the
audience the girls are riding for
[Music]
vampir let me hear another one of his
songs let's let's try this one
Andra should we ask him first if he has
these uploaded anywhere yeah probably
this one's called androgynous uh I guess
I should wait I'm I want to play it
though I'm not going to do it I'm going
to regret it if it gets claimed and then
like they never they don't even know how
to remove it it's like a whole nightmare
forever all right a nightmare a
nightmare it's a
nightmare so uh at this
point we can move on to something that
I've been looking forward to talking
about which is the documentary Wars
that Jimmy Lee has caught himself in the
center of a
[Music]
hurricane old timey turned into a bad
timey Jimmy Lee has
absolutely is his career in in Peril I
don't know there's a lot of people upset
at Jimmy there's there's a lot of
emotions are high uhhuh it's interesting
um
Jimmy
so uh
um H what's his name Mike Clum yeah
thank you sorry Mike Mike
Clum um when he called
in he had explained that Jimmy he had
shot a whole lot documentary with Jimmy
Mike and because he was taking too long
which I think was just only a few months
really yeah uh Jimmy started to work
with this other documentarian Alex
documentarian
documentarian Alex who put out the Jimmy
Lee um documentary which is a very good
documentary that I suggest people to
watch but um there's some drama Alex saw
that and he got upset because he felt
that Mike was accusing him of
plagiarizing and now my interpretation
of that interview with Mike is not that
I I felt that Mike was being very very
um kind and and flat and complimentary
to you I think if anything he's blaming
Jimmy right but um so Jimmy first of all
okay here's statements from all the
parties let's start here let's start
with the first
exhibit yeah let's get some kind of um
CSI yeah so so uh Jimmy has never put
anything like this
out so if you started a doc with someone
and then was ghosted after spamming them
for months would you not think that's
out the door do you think Jimmy wrote
this it's not like in his voice he use
the word ghosted out the door I feel
like Jimmy wrote that ghosted though no
he wouldn't say ghosted he said it when
we were on the phone with him hey Mason
write something up yeah for sure you got
someone to write this for I'm not young
like you guys I don't have time oh my
bro I said that
jokingly but I I do think that he just
thinks he's going to die soon and he's
got to get the ball going yeah he's in a
hurry Alex hopped on it and completed it
whatever I was being goofy definitely
wrote this okay this is a MD by the or
well no not a MD but this is a doctor
you'll know he if he wrote it if there's
like typos and ATS in it cuz he always
like there's always ATS and like
that at sign yeah interesting like that
what is it he's Shand he's a Shand kind
of guy yeah Alex hopped on it and
completed it whatever I was being goofy
apologizing after you hearing how many
views the Boogie doc got thought you
guys would understand that by now it's a
comedy podcast I'm on after all who is
this guy I've never heard Jimmy talk
like
this because it's probably not him but
he posted it I thought he's the only
he's the one with posting power I'm
looking I'm going through my text with
him right now it doesn't seem like his
General uh verbiage I gotta ask him who
wrote this Zach oh Mike is I love that
he'll drop anything to call into the
show pretty much like when have we ever
been like get Jimmy on the line and he
didn't answer the call and guy he owns
like five dentist practices ain't no
ways he he would walk away midp patient
to call into the show you want him you
want him on the line yeah let's get him
on the line I got to know what happened
here I'm an older guy oh God he's really
laying it on he says Mike is doing fine
everybody's fine nobody is hurt I'm an
older guy you guys are attacking for no
reason right now that's uncalled for you
think my documentary would have even
blown up like boogies let's be
real I mean that's true I don't know
that that's true yeah it's definitely
true I mean who's Jimmy Lee people know
who Boogie
is okay but I think I mean who knows
though I mean it's done quite well on
Alex's not I don't want to take away
from Alex yeah it's done fine for being
I mean I I I agree with what Jimmy's
saying there if Mike had made a
documentary he probably would have got a
similar amount of views right good for
Mike for going with Boogie good for me
for going with Alex all is well you
can't just take what a person say and
run with it or humans were complex
getting used to get mad at every little
thing where in the end no one's getting
hurt that's true Jimmy if nobody's hurt
um I mean Mike did waste a lot of time
but he doesn't seem too cross about it
he was he wasn't he was the only he the
only one who's not upset he's the only
one that got over yeah he seemed
like I guess people got mad at Jimmy
when they heard about what happened
right uh when Mike said Alex stole Clips
how could that happen if nothing was
released what Mike didn't specify was he
meant stole the same filming location
that's all did he use the word stole I
don't remember stole I don't recall him
ever saying Alex stole I don't think so
I think I think Mike said that yeah you
went to the same locations and like
right which I guess got interpreted as
like you were ripping off but he I the
way I interpreted is it's Jimmy Lee he's
one person he has one set of friends he
has one brother he has one comedy club
that he hangs out with they he takes him
to the same location yeah it's gonna
it's G to be a similar thing yeah I get
it oh Jimmy said he'll call in in 10
minutes all right he's finishing up on a
rot Canal he's he's driving he's
probably out to dinner yeah he's at the
deli for
sure um so this is interesting this is a
new side of Jimmy I can't is he
defending himself maybe he's defending
Alex interesting Alex was upset by this
situation um Alex is in chat Alex
noville my doc got as many views as
Jimmy as actual followers on Instagram
there it is that is true that's true and
Jimmy that's your official documentarian
saying that so hi Alex welcome uh to
chat we appreciate you and let me check
on the let me check on the the dock let
me see what you've done here you did a
great job too by the way I mean let's
put it in perspective because Mike he's
a professional and he works with people
I seemed like you really put that
together um oh thank you you really put
that together uh yourself I I'm assuming
and it's quite impressive it brought me
to tears Olivia was crying my God just
about famous the Jimmy Lee documentary I
recommend everybody watch it I mean damn
by the way speaking of which did we get
a hold of the MS boss yes we did so
we're we're we're gonna you and me we're
gonna talk after the show okay good I'm
excited I'm excited for Jimmy to not
know anything about
it it happens still I mean this is shot
like super classy I love it majority of
things that happen in this area are
funny so that's Alex is this got 50,000
views that's
great
um so let's continue on with the
statements
here there's another post by Jimmy Hi
everyone right now it seems like I am
the enemy again I just because people
are always mad at
Jimmy I I
just yeah I mean like I find it
interesting that of all the times people
have been mad at
him that this is the one time he had to
come out and defend himself I've never
seen it I want to assure everyone that
this is all a misunderstanding Mike and
I were in the works of a documentary
before Alex and I were involved after no
response from Clum for 3 months after
repeated attempts to reach him to know I
had given up I know what that means
though Jimmy to be fair you were texting
him like a thousand times a day and he
was trying to live a normal
life
um after no response from Clum for three
months after uh repeated attempts I had
given up Alex reached out to me by email
and asked if I wanted to make a Doc so I
went with Alex thank you I'm very
satisfied that I chose the right person
to do the film for me I am now aware
that he did not say say that Alex stole
his content and it was a
misunderstanding okay
nice things are heating up
man it's an old timey conflict you
know all right let me see what did I get
here the chicken
pesto this thing looks pretty
[Music]
intense you people complain about
hearing me
I'm so far
[Music]
away the chicken uh
chapra I don't think so why is there an
extra roast
beef oh Lord this looks good I'll switch
if there's
confusion
[Music]
Olivia so um the drama is is
continuing the documentary documentarian
who ended up doing Jimmy's doc left this
comment about the
situation oh
boy alex said I worked super hard on my
doc about Jimmy I heard a lot to hear
Mike say I basically stole the idea from
him when Mike was literally making a hit
piece on
[Music]
Jimmy you
know I think it's kind of harsh but he
might be it might be that Mike's
documentary would be more critical I
think Alex took a really like
humanistic kind of
uh very just a very neutral showing of
Jimmy and what his life is like you know
and I could definitely see
Mike not that it's wrong or a bad thing
but you
know I think Mike is as a documentarian
more interested in like telling a story
mhm which isn't bad it's good when I met
Jimmy he told me he had filmed with
Mike for four days and all of Jimmy's
team told me how worried they were that
it was a hitpiece documentary his team I
got to know who you talk to I love Jimmy
and I've been a fan of HD since 2013 so
it was super sad for me to hear people
say my project is lesser than Mike's
non-existent Jimmy Lee documentary I put
real time into my film and have true
love in my heart for Jimmy I'm super
broken after this and not sure what to
do next I also interviewed Jimmy's
brother which took a lot of hard work
and emotional discussions with Jimmy
there's also where I got all the
archival footage from which Mike never
did so I'll say this Alex your work was
phenomenal specifically all the archival
work and then bringing his brother into
it was uh was a was a Masterwork amazing
I do I have I do fear that you might be
taking Mike's words I don't I don't
think he accused you of stealing
anything you know I think from your part
it's totally understandable what
happened uh was definitely
Jimmy
um that Mike over not
you uh no please let me call in I tell
you are you
sure you want to call on with Jimmy I
mean that'd be interesting let's keep
let's keep the let's do it let's do it
that's what Alex call him the
documentary Wars are heating up
man cardon's coming too let's get them
all oh
people say I chew with my mouth
open what's this because I'm
talking because I'm trying to do a show
how am I supposed to talk with my mouth
closed I'm not Jeff
Dunham
not going to do
it and then I go like this to cover it
and people go he's
soy look how soy Ethan is covering his
mouth who said that some people are
saying that's my
ick that's the funniest I've ever
heard in my lifeu soy because you cover
your mouth as you speak they said that's
my I I'm obsessed that's you problem
that's funny that's on you you know
that's an Nick to call it an Nick
exactly y That's a reverse ick so well
since Alex is calling in then we'll just
wait and talk to him Mike responded
though so now Mike has made a statement
everybody's forced to make a statement
on this uh hey guys just to clarify I
don't think Alex plagiarized my film in
anyway he did a great job and brought
additional scenes and ideas that I had
him given a range of commitments I have
my process takes between six U to 12
months I understand this wasn't the
timeline that was fit for Jimmy who was
anxious to keep things moving and I
mentioned I needed more time Alex didn't
see my footage but we did both shoot in
a lot of similar locations and discuss
similar things this is why I said
replica but that was the wrong word to
use in insinuated malice intent which
there was none by Alex I do think Jimmy
should have been more forward with me
about his involvement in another
documentary and I would have happily
collaborated but this is ultimately okay
and this is how things happen in
business they interview was my first
major public interview I was a bit
nervous and excited and should have been
more respectful to Alex and his team for
the original work they did I encourage
everyone to check it out I think he's I
think again Mike to Mike is being very
gracious I don't I think Mike I don't I
mean I think you both are totally fine
both of you guys you know
just is Jimmy did
this this is an old timey thing
happening here this is not your guys's
fault Jimmy cause this whole thing too
we weren't going to talk about um Mike
working on his Jimmy do until Jimmy
messaged us so he he shoehorned himself
into the drama
here
true um in dub We Trust said what is
this about the eel pit is this a eel are
you eel pit Associated well I have a
second let me speak for the audience oh
never mind I misread that we see you
putting off the E pit no the eel Pit's
going to we're doing that
next right after this right after this
MH so is there more there's more posts
and Jim like Jimmy put this on a
chalkboard graphic what the this
one is Jimmy for sure cuz look at the
spacing the enters but where do you get
this template dude must have downloaded
like an app like good app he just like I
don't know it's written in Pros
yeah it's awesome so this one may have
been Jimmy he said hi everyone right now
it seems like I am the enemy oh didn't I
read this
one yeah I read this one yeah a
different version of it I guess I like
this version better yeah all right so I
have um card
cardamon
cardamon the lobby and I also have Alex
the documentary filmmaker let's stay
focused card sorry I let's follow let's
continue the thread and let's talk have
him as a third wheel in this
conversation let's let's try to keep
it so bring Alex
in
um sorry
choking I mean I'm I'm fascinated by all
this it's pretty
incredible
all right um he's here he doesn't seem
to be paying attention I don't know if
he knows that he's in here Alex he
hasn't connected his
audio oh there we go
Alex one sec let me mute the okay cool
there we go I had to mute the
show
hello how are you uh I'm doing great
great to sorry to cut I was just saying
I hope you're feeling better about the
situation because I'm I'm feeling really
good from the get-go when I called Mike
I don't know if you watched the video
that I put out but when I called Mike he
was very understanding about the whole
situation and I was just like look like
I feel like there's like some
misconceptions because I just started
getting like bombarded like all of a
sudden I've never seen something because
I'm like a really small guy I've never
seen something like this where like I
was getting all this love on the dock
and everyone was really into it and then
like you guys had that episode with with
Mike and then like all this hate started
flowing in and all these comments on the
dock of people being like I'll read one
to you right now yeah go ahead I'm
curious what people were saying that
might explain why the mbos segment is so
out of place gotta got to rep the msbos
by the way dude I love mbos work we're
working on getting him no I I've been
talking to him I've been I've been
coaching him for we're Bing him we we
shot I shot something with him on
Saturday and I just put it up on my
channel this morning um it's like an
extra Star Wars like heavy star Wars
mozzarella boss bringing old mozzarella
back power of the force yeah yeah so
anyways so someone said like uh they
said maybe the doc was about Jimmy and
his friends but I think the other guy
should have done the doc boogies was way
better quality than this and I think
like the thing is is there was never
comparison of the two docks and because
of that episode there's just all this
comparison between well Mike could have
done Jimmy's story and I just put out a
video to say say like look if Mike had
done it it might have been different I
have no ill will towards Mike I just
felt like I had to defend my doc I had
to defend Jimmy because Jimmy Jimmy did
he's not being very clear about this but
like uh Olivia the girl who works with
Jimmy she reached out uh to you guys I
think and sent you an email so Olivia
works for Jimmy different person not me
what did she what did she email us she I
think she guys she sent you guys an
email uh with like text screenshots of
her calling Mike Clum and telling him
basically that Jimmy didn't he was
worried about the doc I'm not really
sure because I just I she was texting me
about all of this and I think it's more
like her her side of the story than mine
but I just wanted to say my piece of
that like Mike understood that I that
like as a filmmaker I had to say like
look replica is a really weird word and
film making
he I felt because it was very hard to
like get all of that that like I don't
know I just felt like I had to come out
and defend my work I understand Alex one
sec can we get Olivia on the call yeah
we're gonna get and Jimmy's gonna be
joining us soon so we'll get to the oh
my God this is a can we get the
mozzarella boss on too that's on you I
do we have his number yes I do his
number let's get the let get Theos in
here you we got to get the whole
can we get guch do you guys have Joey
gaba's
number I can give you gaba's number
Olivia Gaba oh that's the guy at the
diner Gaba deuch is Jimmy sidekick he's
a very important character in all this
he's just kind of he's quiet he'll just
kind of sit there in the corner and be
quiet yeah yeah yeah guch is very
important absolutely
so yeah I I see how why that comment
would be upsetting
although I think think you know I and
also sorry sorry to interrupt but he
implied that that they were that Jimmy
was taking me around and showing me like
places and stuff my whole family is from
Cherry Hill uh so I I kind of like we
would set intentions for the day of like
what the story would be but it this was
all kind of like I'm a longtime fan of
the show and this is like my love letter
to Jimmy and to the show so it it's not
it wasn't like uh it wasn't like how it
was implied that like Jimmy was taking
me to the diner Jimmy was taking me the
only place Jimmy took me is whenever we
shot the street comedy we had to like
kind of stay and follow him and I had to
coach my camera people to be like this
is we got this is the reward he gets for
the day we we did a lot of hard work
today and this is what he wants to do so
how many people did you work with on
this uh on this documentary so I like
finan this all out of pocket um with
like five grand um and it was just me my
best friend Josh from college my friend
Yuki who's a really talented
cinematographer and filmmaker um there's
like maybe 10 people total who worked on
the the movie but oh wow I uh uh I just
like called in every favor and like
every person I I know from like working
professionally doing like stuff in my
day job and then like stuff outside of
that just trying to like I feel like I
just had this story to tell about Jimmy
like so connected to him it's so
sad you guys talk every day I'm assuming
like well constantly that's Jimmy and I
are kind of like on the Rocks right now
actually we haven't talked in like four
days and it's really sad to me I'm
hoping when he calls in we can make nice
cuz like he he said I wasn't defending
him enough in the comments and he
thought I deleted one of his comments
and like he just got so upset me cried
over I ate a Costco rery chicken and I
cried and sobbed and like Jimmy hates me
Jimmy hates me why does it and Larry
called me Larry called me on the phone
and he's like I'm sorry about what's
happening to you man like Larry Jimmy's
brother right yeah Larry so he's even
involved in this this is this this this
drama is far reaching this is like a
Fallout this is international could we
have everybody
affective that's up no no Jimmy
Jimmy is that that's too far that's too
far I won't do that to
him I'm talking too much I'm sorry guys
I'm a little hopped off I think I I
Olivia U messaged me on Discord I don't
I I don't know if this is her I
Instagram dm' her okay with the zoom
link so you're watching so he got mad at
you because you weren't defending him
it's that's um this is a
mischaracterization Jimmy is an amazing
person he has extremos C what I found
from working on this film he adjusts the
corners of things and he flips the
lights on and off and does stuff his mom
would do which is like incredible like
classical OCD but he also in conjunction
with that has what we call old-fashioned
New Jersey lead
poisoning so maybe he's not histrionic
maybe he's just lead poisoning over a
lifetime of tap the people from that
town like the people from Cherry Hill
like my grandparents are like Leed the
up they're just filled with lead
oh that is so
insightful so tell me about the timeline
though because so all this there was
kind of a Fallout you got upset after
the mic won it sounds you guys resolved
it and I'm happy about that because I
think you're both good dudes so I I I
hate to see Mike's a great guy Mike is a
and his movie did so well and like you
his movie did amazing and it's
incredibly way more polished than mine
he did put $20,000 into his film and I
put 5,000 into mine but I do want to
emphasize how amazing what you
accomplished was specifically getting
his brother and all the um Nostalgia
shots I mean that that was really
professional the way that that all came
together um I appreciate that thank you
actually I never asked Jimmy what was
his response to seeing his brother in
the documentary because that was kind of
a big deal he knew Larry was going to be
in a he we we he knew like took a lot of
convincing to like tell the story of the
brothers and all of that and like I kind
of tipped toed around like the the main
issue of why why and how and I won't get
into all of that you know what happened
though yeah but you can't obviously you
wouldn't say no it's not your place it's
it's like it's like the wife and kids
it's like you just you don't go there
it's yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah damn
that's sad though it seems like his bro
like really wants to um reconcile that's
this I guess the sad part but you must
have really
Jimmy
um uh you no comment you don't have to
comment yeah you don't have to com
that's say yeah no comment so um so
Jimmy's mad but I don't understand why
Jimmy would be mad at you you didn't you
didn't do anything say anything about
him he was just upset like at the whole
situation and I think he's never this is
what M Mason called me and he's like
listen Alex Jimmy is fomo the up he
got 500 hate comments he's just on fomo
overload like you have to you have to
let him chill and I'm like no like I was
trying to I was trying to produce
something else with Jimmy we we're
trying to work on this other project and
like I was trying to get like a sponsor
involved oh look Olivia's here hi Olivia
all right we've got another uh member in
the
call Jimmy's calling as again joining as
well hold it so Olivia I can't see I
can't see
Olivia I can't see anyone but Alex at
the moment
oh it's a jump scare when jimmmy comes
look at him Jesus Christ God we
need Mason in here that's I need we do
need we need Mason we do he texted me so
get here I need the whole Jimmy can you
guys hear me yeah I can see and I can
hear you yeah we can hear you
hello Olivia can I just can I just text
him that link yeah just send it to me
soon so Olivia what what do you do for
uh
Jimbo um I encourage Jimmy to be the
best version of himself that he can be
when I get to see him in the city hi
Jimmy Jimmy is uh he is serious today
Jimmy are you nonverbal today what's
going on you seem kind of harsh you're
not talking JY I straighten my
hair and oliv uh Olivia are you are you
a paid employee or what is your
Association no no no it's pure of the
game um yes well actually it started out
where I have this like meme page myself
and like I would just DM Jimmy like hey
you should delete this because like
I and so I be like okayy this yeah this
one's definitely
racist and some people need that
soundboard you know don't do the camel
joke you someone needs to tell you that
some people need the extra love and
sorry about my bird in the
back sorry I have a pet parrot oh no I
can't even hear you're good you're good
you're
good so um but they you're referred to
as someone on Jimmy's team would you
consider yourself to be on his
team yes always on Jimmy's side always
have his back
Jimmy you really have these these people
they really care about
you I see Alex talk about you he really
he really does seem to have a soft spot
for you A lot of these people they
endeared to you Jimmy Jimmy Jimmy what
come on oh Mason's
joined Mason it's so nice to see you um
very to finally talk you guys Mason nice
to connect I don't think we've ever
connected like this I don't think so
this just so great this is exactly what
I want huge dude this is huge awesome
who can we get can we get gu in here we
get mozzarella we're working on it yeah
we're working on it he said he's trying
Mason umer was there the day that he
filmed with Mike so if you could send
the link to peebler oh PE peebler we
gotta get PE we gota get pee in here too
we gotta send the link to anyone you
guys must no no yeah let's can I just
put the link yeah just put the
L whoever you want no no I'll send it
I'm kidding you have the you have the
exclusive distinction of being the only
paid uh p uh uh employee of jimmies how
does that feel uh it feels good feels
good I love doing it I love making the
memes and so it's just so much fun
overall you're really good at it you got
a wild mind dude dude thank you thank
you yeah I try to just be crazy just
whenever I can just go crazy
with it Al do I do want to ask are you
the one that made the meme about um
Osama Bin Laden parachuting from the
World Trade Center and saying all timey
probably I wouldn't be surprised not
Kidd
who makes those
ones any of the yeah it was probably me
then yeah it was I make a lot and is
this your full-time gig uh
Mason right now yeah I was a manager at
like restaurants and stuff and then I
used to do stream but now I just do this
videos we do his videos to and that's
that's honestly so cool Jimmy that uh
that Mason has found himself a really
cool job doing something that he loves
for example I mean this meme really
changed everything changed after this
day the devil gets chills when the nice
guy loses his temper my Roman Empire oh
my this is your Roman Empire AB because
you think about it every week all the
time yeah so Jimmy you haven't said
anything what's going on um letting
everybody have their platform being
being
considerate Jimmy are you call me
back Jimmy how why is it that
you've Jimmy why is it you've avoided uh
talking to Alex for the last four
days Jimmy you're being very your
histrionic uh personality disorder has
evaporated any comment about the Alex
situation
Jimmy
did the lead poisoning thing did you
hear about that that he says you may
have lead
poisoning no Mad Hatters disease Mad
Hatter's disease some call it Jimmy do
you think it's possible that you
consumed a lot of lead over your
lifetime no sir no in the pipes in New
Jersey Jimmy come on maybe James Wier
has James oh oh oh game hey
Gabe Gabe nice to see you man how are
you it's nice to see you not on a Friday
on a Monday in fact like the the
opposite
Jimmy oh it's M's boss let's go the mo
boss in that
house my boy that internet is not
looking too good over there but oh we're
here the lighting M's
boss boss one only you're a star man
you're the breakout character I mean my
God everybody's asking who is the MZ
boss and how do we get
more well let me put on my mozzarella
boss hat yeah yeah finally you know I
got to get in full gear Jimmy's mad okay
Jimmy Jimmy any comment on the
proceedings big Gul wow that's a huge
Gul what are you drinking anyway I'm a
long
for what are you drinking Jimmy water
Jim I have a no that wasn't water bring
it back water Ethan I have a be with you
you okay Gabe beef with you Jimmy Le
wait Gabe has a beef with Jimmy what
happened I don't even know anything what
what did Jimmy do to you
Gabe what the you you you ran
Jersey baby
you ran Jersey not me I ran Jersey
I'm the king of Jersey especially mat
pane I I ran
Jersey I'm the I've been behind says he
runs
JY I run Jersey does anybody else want
to claim that they run
Jersey I I run Jersey runs
Jersey it never was theey James you have
uh some conflict of uh Turf are you
claiming New Jersey as yours or are you
cons are you conceeding to uh these two
me yeah you I'm the jersey at they all
know I run New
Jersey platform they know that they
don't even know him at the Jersey Shore
oh they know mpot say the Jersey Shore
yeah yeah mat I ran mantan baby mantan
all
right Olivia Olivia do you live in New
Jersey or you local
uh no I'm from New York oh you're from
New York you're a city slicker City
Slicker yeah nice we love that and Mason
where are you are not you don't have to
dox yourself I'm just curious if you're
local with all these folks no I'm in
Northern California like Sacramento oh I
see I see and and Alex you do you live
on the east coast near jimmmy or what
did you trans did you drive out there or
trans travel out there
buwick say what Brooklyn Bushwick oh
another city slicker
huh big city
so Jimmy from the St Jimmy we've
got quite an ensemble of people that
really admire and care about you um this
is quite inspiring thank you I
appreciate that now do you want to talk
about here to
say MZ boss are you
um are you thinking of uh selling the
mozzarella are we bottling it are we
going International or
national we're we're just I've been just
doing it for fun having a good time not
really you know just just enjoying
myself doing it you know Jimmy was
famous and you know what I'm going to
make myself famous since since as we
know behind the uh one fed up Dennis
going back seven years
ago you were involved in that right
Jim I was I was the one that actually
said Jim just be yourself you're funny
when you're one up Dennis oh
because I've been friends with
Jim I ran Atlantic City
going says he runs Atlantic
City that's true Jim is that the guy we
know from the Cino to paper wrap chicken
yes oh my God these two
are used to go get the
free
Jersey that was a little that was a
little mean don't you think MZ boss no
no I don't I didn't mean him I Jim and I
used to go Jim used to take me to dinner
at the casino with his uncle and the guy
would make his paper WRA chicken you
literally okay you're you're thinking of
an actual literal person it wasn't like
a racial joke no no not at
all okay you're
racist I turned Seaside
that's my boy Gabe you're doing I
love it CL Gabe we love
you so Jimmy um what's going on with
Alex I I hate to see that there's some
kind of Rift formed between the two of
you he did a good movie on me and uh I
thanked him for that that's it pretty
much Alex that's not exactly true is
it um Jim we've been we've been talking
we've been we've been working on
something and and uh you just kind of
ghosted me a little bit and also like I
thought I just thought we were friends
we said you said we were going to go to
ponzio
together Jimmy go ahead I don't have
anything really to say e to be honest
with you I'm a very good movie on me and
I thanked him for that and I was
appreciative of the movie he did a great
job yeah Mo your mozzarella isn't it
a you're breaking my heart Jimmy
you're really breaking my heart I think
that that comment really got to Gabe and
I understand why Gabe you're you're your
your anger love you we love you Gabe
you're you're part of New Jersey buddy
Olivia did you want to say something you
were putting your hand up uh um I just
feel like you know Jimmy he's a complex
guy a funny guy so sometimes you know
things go up and down but he's the star
and you know you gotta make it work and
Alex made it work with Jimmy and Jimmy
got his
movie um yeah I wasn't really gonna
insert much there so you can follow the
conversed you yeah that ghosted you
yeah he did um Olivia I want to you
really are are really good at your job I
mean you're doing PR you're managing
Jimmy and it seems like I can't say it
seems like a thank it might sound like a
thankless job at times and I think I
think you're doing a really good job so
I congratulate you on
that oh thank you Jimmy may not agree
but thank you um Mason Olivia and Alex
are you guys in a group chat at all do
you guys communicate about that no no we
kind of I'll talk through me okay yeah
yeah um Jimmy there is definitely some
tension between you and Alex that I just
don't understand Alex you're really
funny he
says he's a funny guy what does he what
does he mean by that you are a really
funny guy
Jimmy what is going on dude you so upset
you haven't talked to me since Friday
when all this kind of when the hit
the
fan I tell I I told you I love you man I
love you so much like that's why I told
your story that's why we did this thing
and like I I just don't understand why
you're treating me like I like I wronged
you in some way and why you cut me off I
was we we talk like maybe nine to 10
times a day sometimes and suddenly zero
phone calls not a text and then he texts
me Heats me with the K like that's
nothing and leaves me on red Jimmy do
you think it's possible that whatever
perceived slight may have happened uh
that's uh pushed you away from Alex I do
genuinely think that Alex doesn't know
what he did wrong and I think it it'd be
a good maybe time to communicate so that
we could mend some bridges
here I there's nothing really to say to
be honest I told you he made a movie on
me he did a really nice job making a
movie he really did the documentary is
really well
done Jimmy do you think Alex was
deleting comments like in no you know
what you know what here's the here's
what it is here's what it is here we go
here's what it is here's what it is guys
the a couple days before the movie came
out I sent Jimmy a copy of the movie and
he called me and he said you need to
redo the entire thing it's very boring I
don't like the mozzarella boss the
mozzarella boss has to be
completely and and he just like and to
be honest you guys to be honest I
screamed at him I fullon screamed at him
on the phone I like I've never let loose
on somebody like that and I apologized
to him for it I was very apologetic but
it there was a huge leadup to this of
him calling me a snorer because he said
I didn't pay for the meal for his crew
he wanted me to take everybody out to
balazar and it turned into this whole
thing and now we're like at odds with
each other off this weird and it's
like come on Jimmy
working out I understand I'm not a
snorer I put out five grand for the
movie and and also like the movie
everyone loved the movie it was good it
didn't get a ton of views it didn't make
you famous but like it was a good movie
people liked it and like now you like
want to treat me like I'm the devil
because I didn't turn you into Sylvester
Stallone Jimmy was his recounting of
that accurate whoa the second angle is
really sorry whoa I was just like that's
that's craphy boss how do you feel
knowing that Jimmy was lobbying to
remove your uh
[Music]
section well I always don't forget me
and J Jim and I go back since
1985 that was when I was born I know I
know Jim and he knows me and you know he
you know he was bound to become famous
and the movie did finally come out and
then I had to put my two sense into it
and say you know what I got let's let's
face reality um I got no never once does
he ever mention about me and my
involvement what with one effed up
Dennis how I came up with the idea ABC
always be cleaning and all the stuff
that went along so he had seven years of
Fame and you know it was wiener wiener
time with the w well now it's the flip
let's flip the switch maybe it's going
to be mozzarella time you know with the
m
I'm sensing I'm sensing um this is
really interesting
because I'm sensing there's a little
resentment um mozzarella boss not just
for the his suggestion of cutting you
from the film but it I'm sensing you
feel you've not been credited enough in
his rise to fame correct correct correct
can I can I say one thing absolutely
we'd love to hear from you the only
thing he said true was the the uh the
always clean teeth he did he did do that
part in the one after up Dennis and the
one up that Dennis was my videographer
John Bell's idea it wasn't Rob's idea
and Rob was put into the movie because
he was a friend and the only thing he
said true was always be cleaning teeth
that was his skit from I used matz BOS
do you have a response to that my
response is Jim I said you're funny when
you're yourself
I said you're one up dentist and
that's what the video should be I said
you should go with that theme not the
outlaw you're not the outlaw you're the
dentist that's interesting we've been
trying to give him the same advice MZ
boss uh Jimmy did he come up with that
name funny when he's himself no he
didn't come up with the idea it was John
Bell that came up with the idea Rob did
say that I should be the one after up
dentist but the problem is it hurt my
business gr so I do Street but he didn't
come up with the idea and he didn't do
everything to make me famous I've done
everything myself and Rob was in one of
the episodes that's the truth well Jimmy
you know some people
say uh there's a there's a line in a
drink song that I can't recall but it's
something about when you rise up you got
to bring your people with you maybe M's
boss feels left behind a little bit and
your rise to fame I I do feel still a
little left behind Ethan right you know
well that's just I do I mean here me and
him we go back since 1985 I was washing
his uncle's
boat uh you know we we had many many
good times and uh you know when he got
to the top I got kicked to the curb wow
that's that's that's also a total that's
also Rob such a total
lie um you're really a liar you're
really you think it's a joke it's really
not a joke and you really hurt act like
you're the reason I got famous I've been
breaking my balls at this
for 25 years you were in one of my
freaking videos you are not the reason I
am where I'm at don't even play it's not
nice Jim Rob Rob Rob don't insult me on
H3 who I who I love and I pride myself
on and lie to them on the air and say
you made me famous because it's not a
joke cuz you did not you have done
nothing for me you were on one of my
episodes and that was it so don't
them it's not right it's wrong
don't lie jimy made himself famous Jimmy
definitely made himself make himself
famous to lie to Ethan hold on Jimmy
it's wrong to lie to people Rob and do
that because you're lying it's not right
Jimmy if I can interject if I can
interject a bit I don't think Jimmy he
was accusing you of of I don't think he
was saying he's solely responsible for
for your success I think he just I think
he feels a little left behind and I
think he's being raw and he's being
emotional and he's being real for you
right now just to say like as a longtime
friend since 1985 he he wants to be more
included in in all the amazing things
you have going
on he has invited me though Jim has for
the record he's invited me to New York
he's invited me to La he even invited
invited
doesn't come to anything but he came to
came to the thing when Alex filmed
because he wanted to be
included the things that can get him
noticed but when I invite him to go to
New York to Little Italy and do a lot of
other things he doesn't do
them this is a new dialogue emerging
here MZ boss that suggest that uh
perhaps you could be more supportive but
perhaps you're just uh
uh pursuing the
clout I I have to interject here before
Rob responds go ahead I'm sorry Jimmy is
saying that he is in he invites Rob to
Little Italy and stuff like that he
invites gu and people to do stuff like
that too but it's it's hard because it's
like a full 12-hour day sometimes where
you're with Jimmy you're doing fomo
you're on the street you're running
around and like Jimmy has this insane
energy I mean there was this week where
everybody in New York was sick except
for Jimmy he's like RoboCop or something
I don't understand it so I think like
not everyone has the energy to keep up
with Jimmy and do something like that
and and so like a lot of times people
say like oh no I don't want to go I
don't want to go do the fomo sorry Jimbo
um is that a is that a good accurate
kind of response MZ
boss I I would agree Jim Jim has invited
me many many times for the record yeah
he's invited me to New York he invited
me to meet you guys when you guys first
met and did your thing um you know I I
just have different uh things that I
need to attend to right I mean you're
the daycare cleaning business it's
really important can you talk about the
dayare hold on guys go ahead Jimmy yes
Rob did I invite you when I met Ethan 10
years ago to come yes she did it was
about seven years ago Jim but yes you
did that's also a lotad wait you never
invited me no you did
Jimmy didn't invite me anything
Gabe says he wasn't
invited Gabe I don't know
that inv my friend but you didn't invite
me that's interesting Jimmy your
thoughts about Gabe he says he wasn't
invited well I don't know Gabe very I
met Gabe at your live show in June one
time I like Gabe he's nice but I only
met him once matz boss at this point in
time does anyone want to interject
anything I want to continue the
conversation but Mason Olivia do any of
you guys want to add anything I just
want to give a pause and allow everyone
to
talk I got Co and I'm super high so I'm
trying to
stay so that's pretty interesting
that'll be an interesting experience for
you feel good still positive nice Good
Vibes Mas we love the memes thank you
thank you oliv I don't I don't have but
I sent you guys like an email when like
the whole Deb was going down um but yeah
you guys have an email to pull up so so
mat's boss
um Jimmy's I think called made some kind
of accusation of you being a clout
Goblin do you know what that
is following him now that he's famous
trying to get live off of his tail
coattails yeah the coattails
the coat tails of hit it on the nail
Ethan and so do you do you accept mbos
that you may be riding his
coattails I I cannot accept that no and
why is that other than speaking with you
I that I will give him credit he me
talking to you and the team right now is
because of Jim and because of Al
right this is all because of Jimmy Jimmy
Jimmy is everything Jimmy's the cause of
all this
and this
is I'm a little upset because I feel
like in this room there's a lot of love
and Jimmy I just I sense that you have a
lot of resentment for some of the people
in this chat and I just feel like it's a
shame because I don't feel like it has
to be this way Jim so
Ethan I'm a very intelligent smart
person and sometimes I see things
Mason's aware of this we talk a lot and
I don't say things but it doesn't mean I
don't know things about people and the
things that they do okay so the reason I
am I'm very protective I told this to
Zach tonight of you guys I can list
numerous episodes when things have
possibly threatened you at your live
show in June with somebody I'm not
mentioning
name and other times and I totally
talked to Zack and he'll he'll he'll nod
his head on this and called him told him
told him the truth and and and he tells
me what to do and I tell him the truth
and I never once wrong you Zach am I
right or wrong Zach Zach knows
that oh I don't need Zach to tell me
that though we know that Zach are you
are you not commenting
Zach I mean I I'm very upfront with
Jimmy yeah no I'm a loyal loyal guy
absolutely and that's not questioned at
all that's not questioned at all loyal
loyal to the end just like I'm with my
your loyalty is not in question Jimmy I
promise right so so and my my integrity
and honesty despite my character and my
offens of jokes so when I find out how
people are unfortunately I do sometimes
I get very hurt because deep down I'm a
very sensitive
person and then I kind kind of shy away
from people when they hurt me and do
things that aren't very nice kind of
like why I don't bother with my brother
you see yeah CA I Ethan am a lot like
you and howy you guys are the probably
the most generous nicest guys that I've
met just to be nice to me and I'm not
just saying it to to to kiss your ass
because I'm on the show I'm saying that
as a truth and I like to surround myself
with people that are generally really
nice
and in it for the right reasons um that
really love me for me not for ulterior
motives and if they can get something
from me does that explain it without
having to go into detail Jimmy I love
you for you I love you for you so much I
just want to hang out with you and not
do fomo or anything like hang out you
and me just like you know get do I have
ulterior
motives what's my motive Jim
well you're Ethan Ethan hit it what do
you call Ethan a clout something clout
Goblin I believe it was the yeah Ethan
eth hit that one right on the
head like you I've known you many years
but I do know what you're in it for and
you're a little deceptive with me and
you uh you know you're just you're just
you're just who you are I'm not angry
with you anyway but you're not
forthright and honest and and it makes
me hurt you hurt me and then I kind of
shy away if Ethan's wanting to know the
truth can I interject here because I
feel like Jimmy is actually being quite
vulnerable with us I think being able to
admit that when someone hurts you that
how you shy away I think is a quite a
quite mature and vulnerable thing to to
um my brother my entire life Ethan has
done very mean things to me and this is
why I don't have a relationship so when
people do things to me to hurt me a deep
down I would would do anything for
anybody and give them the shirt off my
back I would give you my last dollar but
if you hurt me or you lie or you're
deceptive with me or you have motives
and the love isn't really there because
I'm an older person now I won't engage
and I will shy away but so do do you and
and being and being so open and honest
with us and vulnerable do you think it's
possible
that sometimes as a defense mechanism
you shy away way when you perceive that
you've been slighted but I think that
being able to recognize that is only
half the battle I think the other battle
Jimmy is being able to confront that
feeling and uh talk with the other
person about it because I think you'll
find most times Jimmy that the the the
harm that you perceive on a personal
level was never
intended and I will I will admit on the
air because I'm far from perfect and
everybody on the H3 crew knows that yeah
I am a non-confrontational person I'm
very bad with that I'm like that with my
employees and uh I I shy away because I
don't like confrontation and conflict
and and and that's that's my problem
that I have to work with so I Ethan
that's a very valid point and okay
you're right you're all right on that I
will give you that one because I I I
hate to see like let's just start for
example with Alex I mean Alex is really
he put a lot on the line to make this
documentary for you he spent a lot of
money and um I just you know I I don't
see why you guys can't just connect
let's say this Jimmy he slided you and
you're
feeling again let's recognize what it is
a defense mechanism and we all have them
and so you see yourself um cuz you don't
want to get hurt and and you don't want
to even go there because it hurts so bad
to be betrayed by someone you love as a
friend but I think that I think that if
you guys can make a connection
and that that's how you heal Jimmy you
know what I mean CU if you if you just
withdraw you you leave in pain you leave
with an open wound and we need to allow
these wounds to
heal okay you said Jimmy you told me
that you loved me you said that we were
like brothers and oh oh hi SP so I
really bonded I really bothered Alex
with you a lot till I got wrong by you a
few times that's why backed off you know
my brother you're a lot like my brother
Jimmy that's you're treating me like
your actual brother dude I I love you
and I care about you I want the best for
you I want to bring you to the level
that you actually that I promised you
when I made this movie I said I want to
give you that Fame that you want but
it's a multi-step process it's not just
the movie It's the movie and then it's
another project and then it's another
project and it's like creating a brand
for yourself as not just like a street
comedian but as this host type character
like how or like Ethan like you want to
be you said something interesting Jimmy
Alex did something specifically that
hurt you can would you be comfortable
sharing that with us
today well me and Aira watched the movie
that was the he's hurt me about four
times but the first one was we watched
the
movie and we called him and we suggested
changes and he started to scream and
curse at me and Akira and Akira actually
take the phone call because she was she
couldn't believe it and she said I'm
going to take this because people won't
believe he did it so I said take it I
said I don't think you should tape it
but he was so rude and he he did this
with um with uh Andrew Callahan's
assistant Jade who called me who
couldn't believe how he talked to her
and I said boy this is being repeated on
me and you know this guy that's a
mischaracterization hold on hold on hold
on Alex let him let him talk this is
important you're you're asking me a
question so Ethan you know I talked to
uh Brad from Newsmax and Mason and about
four people about this and they said
normally there's a round table when you
do a movie and there's always people
talking about things that maybe don't
fit or maybe it's too long or maybe
there's too much com in it and uh maybe
the movie should be shorter and I
watched documentary three times and it's
mostly a documentary there's not that
much about as film in so I was
suggesting that um there's too much
comedy in so Jimmy if I hold it hold it
hold it go ahead go ahead the way he
painted my brother and I it made me look
bad not my brother and the mozzarella
boss as much as I'm friends with Rob he
doesn't fit in the movie but um now I
know be fair was very uh shoor in the mo
he put He put him in the movie now I
know why cuz he was going make a movie
on him so he but he didn't tell me that
not making okay hold on hold on wow this
this is okay hold on this is interesting
this is this is what Alex said Jim I put
him in not because he fits in but
because he has the same dreams of you I
said but people won't understand it but
the real reason he put him in was so he
could get a Vibe on him to make a little
movie which he made today so basically
the thing I said to you earlier Ethan
about people having ulterior motives and
not being honest with you that doesn't
build relationships with people that
that's one thing I preface myself
honesty integrity and always doing a lot
for people there's a movie called super
mench with Chef Gordon he talks about
coupons where you're always doing a lot
of things for people and you can redeem
coupons when you want and I built my
dental business on it my relationist
with people on always doing a lot of
nice things for people and then when you
get a coupon if they're a men they
respond so you're asking me honestly I'm
being very honest with you I I I Jimmy I
don't I can't say that I've seen you be
this vulnerable and I really appreciate
it it seems to me if I can extrapolate
the big slight happened between MZ boss
and Alex you believe that Alex and hold
on let me let me paraphrase and let's
see if this is accurate and then you can
respond you think Alex put MZ boss in
the film which was shoehorned in I'll
grant you that because he wanted to
launch another documentary with mbos and
so you he put him in he put him in and I
thought I believed Alex when he said to
me oh no you don't understand Jim movies
B called me an idiot and said he's in
because he has the same dream if you
like go he doesn't fit in the movie and
me and Aira were politely telling him
things to edit and just talking nicely
and He was cursing at me on the phone
saying I don't give a f a about Kira
she's a nobody
social media and helps me and she's a
very is she an employee do you pay her
no no they do social media for me but
she was very hurt and Bas I don't even
want to say what she said about you Alex
but she's right because
you let me can I can I respond can I
respond to this now you can do what you
want Ethan's asking me and I'm being
Buri no no no I just I I'd like to say
my piece here because I feel like I'm
being mischaracterized as someone who's
very angry and I think like go ahead
yeah goad not angry I'm being honest you
are being you are being let hold on guys
let me I got to moderate a little bit
here to keep this uh watchable Jimmy
thank you for being so vulnerable and
honest I'm very grateful Alex obviously
there's been a lot said so let me give
you this time to respond and let's just
let Alex talk so let me hit a couple of
things we'll go in chronological order
Andrew Callahan's producer Jade called
me when the trailer came out she was
very upset because Jimmy promised them
up and down that they would not that he
would not post anything with Andrew I
told Jimmy that I intended on putting
Andrew Callahan in the trailer um and
Jimmy said well if you do that can I
blame the whole thing on you I said
absolutely you did say I could blame it
but I said do not do it because I told
her no you didn't say don't do it you
got stars in your eyes you got stars in
your eyes and we round taed about it and
you decided that it would be a good idea
to includ it in the trailer and we we
all agreed it was my idea I wanted to do
it and I came to you and I said please
can I do this I know you promised them
but I want to release this because I'll
be back in a minute all right well I go
to the bathroom okay thank you Jimmy
that's okay Andrew Andrew made a big
stink about us not releasing any footage
so hold on this is this is a whole
different thing you guys met up with
Andrew caham and in the movie there's a
scene where we meet Andrew yeah and then
he he asked you guys not to use the
footage
he asked Jimmy not to use the footage he
kind of big timed me and and I kept
saying I'm not part of this I'm a
separate filmmaker doing my own thing
I'm going to use this and he kind and I
gave him my number and I said I'm gonna
use this very very soon and he kind of
big time me and ignored me which is fine
um but then his producer Jade called me
and was asking me to remove the video
and I was like absolutely not I I I put
this out there and it's got Jimmy in it
and like you know the tendrils reaching
in it this affects so many people I mean
it's really remarkable this whole movie
was was a crazy disaster in so many ways
but why was it that um that Andrew
didn't want you to include the footage
do you think because he was making his
it was before his comeback and he wanted
to have the most clout from his comeback
and he didn't want us to like scoop him
on like his big return and I didn't care
about his big return because of the
allegations and whatever so I was like
this guy I'm just going to put him
in the trailer you know it is
what it is I mean it's an interesting
part of the movie It's like a huge
interesting thing that Jimmy and Andrew
met like why would that ever happen I
agree it got me intrigued definitely but
I'll say something that I think maybe
Jim uh Jimmy I just want to say that I
gave the girl my word and I felt when he
did it and the girl called me and I told
her to call him and you ripped her a new
a-hole and she called me and said that
guy is the biggest a-hole I ever met not
a good building relationship type of guy
that's said well that's what and then
you did it asked me I'm not trying to
build a relationship with you did it to
me andira when we when we gave you
feedback on the documentary you told me
you told me to reedit the whole movie
Jimmy you said it was bad you said it
was boring you said it had to be
completely a lie lying again hold on
hold on I said you could take a few
things out and shorten it I did not say
redo the whole movie no you said to put
all of the fomo at the beginning
movie I had to put can I make a point um
Jimmy I believe there's something you
might be missing in that you're the
subject of the
documentary ex you're not supposed to
have editorial control of what the
documentary becomes because then it's
just a puff piece and not a genuine
Slice of Life so I think well then I'm
then I'm wrong I thought that there was
a round table and everybody talks and
agrees Maybe I'm Wrong maybe the
filmmaker is creative and does his thing
then then I then I'm wrong I was just so
upset when I raised my voice to you and
I told you this I was so I was so upset
because I told you I said I sent him the
link and this was this was after we had
had a b a big disagreement where he had
we he had said that I had to pay for a
meal for his crew and stuff and and we
and I wasn't going to send him the movie
before it came out but I decided I was
gonna because he kind of like we had
this whole thing and we made right and
he was like okay well I want to see the
movie and I said okay but go home home
and watch it alone please watch it alone
and he watched it on his phone in a
diner with Akira and I was like why did
you do that that's not how to watch this
movie that I like I slaved over I did so
much for this movie and you like you
pissed it away on like watching it at
ponzio on your phone and then
you were like it's bad and I'm like well
it's not bad it's good you watched it in
a d you did say it's bad you said it's
bad no I didn't no you said and the
reason I was upset at Kira was you said
you said it was very emotional at the
end for both of us and Akira goes well
not both of us and I was like I was
upset I was like what the hell Kira what
did I ever do to you now I I think I can
I understand what's Happening Here on
one hand Jimmy you have to appreciate
how much work and time and love Alex put
into creating this
documentary and I think that when you
when he finishes it after long
longlasting uh tons of work to receive
that kind of criticism is
perhaps certainly would make uh me feel
unappreciated but then on the other side
Jimmy I understand that you feel
slighted because of um the potential
collaboration between Alex and M's boss
and you feel like people were uh you
felt deceived in how their relationship
uh came out so I see two very different
um wrongs that we were we perceiving but
I don't think it's anything that we
can't work out it seems Jimmy like I'm
talking to you and you say you didn't
understand how that works so in a
documentary the round T thing is real
but in a documentary Jimmy you're the
subject right so that's the difference
and so we had a round table of producers
by the way who like my friends who all
watched it and gave me feedback just to
clarify so it makes sense Jimmy that you
wouldn't be involved on that just
because you're the subject and it said
you said maybe I'm right so maybe you're
willing to um so if that's how movies
work then and I'm the subject then I
have to when I work with a film person
you know I have to maybe research stuff
and you know talk ahead of time so we're
all kind of on the same playing field
and tell the filmmaker kind of what I'd
like in it and what I expect to make
sure I'm comfortable which I didn't
do I don't think you're going to find
any serious filmmaker that will make a
documentary about you on those terms
okay I'm just and and I'm just saying
that uh because that's how documentaries
work otherwise it's just a PR piece you
know right and then you should attacking
me and telling me that I'm like that I'm
attacking everyone and making really
mischaracterizing me I feel like um
everyone else who I've worked with like
Olivia and peebler and everyone who I've
worked with on the movie and including
Mason too it's a nice things to say and
I think like I was very understandably
like passionate and also like super
upset to hear that you didn't like this
movie texting all my social media people
to create drama and trouble none of them
like that Alex when you
start cuz I was upset you asked me to
pay for a meal you started to text all
my people to text all my people and
create problems and they're text me why
is this guy bothering me you're like a
troublemaker one sec one sec
I understand why
you hold on this is new this is new
information you're a troublemaker hold
on one sec hold on Jimmy we let's let's
figure this out no because I'm angry
because he creates a lot of problems
Ethan for me unnecessarily I
understand constantly and he lies a lot
yes you do that's
not you do hold on guys Olivia has a
interjection I'd like to hear from
her
well wow that was um quite the battle
then but I just I feel like because I
tell the truth Olivia I don't have to
lie that's why okay Jimmy one moment
please Jimmy love you Jimmy okay just um
stay there for a second um but I think
that you guys both have like worked on
this and Jimmy I understand how like a
lot of things for you with the time you
know you're trying to get big really
fast right like you're trying to get big
fast so things have to be in your time
right um I think Alex was like working
with that and also like the whole thing
of like you guys both getting emotional
and like um going back and forth like
while working um I mean man you guys are
getting emotional now and it's making me
lose track of like what you guys are
even saying like I I don't know like I I
forget what I was even saying Olivia can
I ask you did you receive a text from
Alex that you perceived as stirring
oh that's what Jimmy was okay so
basically no no one thought that peebler
thinks like Alex is fine um no one
thinks it's a drama stup people are
actually wanting to talk to Alex and
like have Jimmy like know about the
scenario too because Jimmy was getting
um kind of painted as a guy who like
can't be worked with and like doesn't
have time or consideration for
filmmakers which Alex defended him on so
like now people in the future will know
that you know Jimmy is able to able to
like um be filmed and stuff stuff like
that Mason did what text message did you
receive from
Alex um I don't recall anything with me
I mean we
we you got messages because you told me
Mason you're talking about that when so
what happened was it was we were
supposed to go out on Saturday to
celebrate the movie coming out and what
happened was Jimmy called me and he said
I want to go to Bazar which is a very
expensive restaurant in Manhattan very
very very expensive and mind you he does
not pay his crew so the meal that he
gives them is their payment and he said
listen you never pitch in I want you to
pitch in for the meal at Bazar is that
is that a false characterization Jimmy I
did say that do you know why I said it
and you said you said it because hold on
hold on Jimmy why did you say that why
because this is this this is Alex I got
all these jobs I got all money I got a
big apartment building in New York I
make a lot of money said well grab a
check you're a big shot that's not true
you called me poor a bunch you kept
calling you said I live in the ten you
kept in the ten like what a big shot you
are hold on hold on the ten hold on uh
Alex what what are you um what is your
financial situation if I may ask I am a
freelance producer I do a little bit of
work for MTV
doing like video editing sometimes and I
mostly do work for Media Matters which
is like a uh it's like a you know medium
political activist group right so like
it's a nonprofit I don't make a lot of
money um I don't make a lot of money on
YouTube I finance this all out of my
pocket I live in Bushwick um Jimmy tells
me I'm poor a lot so I'm like Jimmy told
me what a big shot you were all your
connections and how rich you were so I
said grab a check you made me do it
because you egged me on my brother you
did yes you did do you think do you did
did you ever say anything like that to
Jimmy Alex where you were maybe
suggesting that you were uh very
successful very suful this is what
happened the the the night that the
night before we were supposed to go out
I was doing work on the Rock and Roll
Hall of Fame awards I was doing video
editing social media work for them I got
$500 for the night $500 you told me you
get
$3,500 wait a minute I never said that
Jimmy oh my God you're so I'm leaving
you're full of you're such Jimmy
don't leave we're we're work we're we're
getting to somewhere he lies about
everything he's a liar man he
told me $3,500 to do that he told me
he's a big Jimmy can you just
sit I can't stand being lied to about Li
Jimmy how about this
Jimmy hold on hold on hold on maybe
Jimmy just if you want to just take a
maybe I don't know if you want to excuse
yourself and cool off but please come
back come back okay I think like
jmy hold on one sec guys m boss you have
something to
say Ethan and everyone including Jimmy
Lee and Alex and all the great people at
H3 thank you for having me I have to go
I appreciate everything the show's
great cheese can't
wait Mo boss one last thing I wanted to
ask you if you're not in if it's not
urgent
um did you go behind Jimmy's back and
attempt to become the star of your own
documentary that is something he brought
up absolutely not right I would I would
never in fact I even said to Alex why do
I have such a big part in this it should
have been five minutes Alex why did he
have such a big part in it I would love
to address that because there's been a
lot of controversy surrounding the
mozzarella boss's scene and I think like
the movie is not about Jimmy or the
mozzarella boss or any of that the movie
is called just about famous it's about
like this Jimmy is like an empty void of
want uh and of desire and even if he got
Sylvester Stallone famous today he would
still want more in more he's like this
empty void of want and need and that's
like a relatable interesting thing for
an audience I think like thematically
tied in yeah I see that makes sense can
can I also just say I'm a really small
time guy I'm not I feel like there's a
lot of mischaracterizations being made
about me at the very beginning of my
career on the internet here this is like
my first thing you guys and like it's
with Jimmy Lee and I worked with him for
like four or five months and we talked
every day like obviously there's some
volatility there but like I'm being like
attacked here and I am very very uh
defensive obviously but also like uh I I
I like don't know what to do this is I'm
very well Alex I'll say I don't think
that you need to feel overly defensive
simply because I don't think anyone
besides Jimmy thinks you really did
anything that
wrong so I think the the problem that
I'm focuses on is more the interpersonal
relationship between the two you guys
because professionally Alex I don't
think you have anything to worry about
from this situation to be frank with you
well I should just stop looking at chat
to be honest that's that always a good
uh yeah let's not look at chat hi
chat all right but um Mason May the
force be with you all right May the
force be with you so
much talk tomorrow yeah we'll talk
tomorrow all right sounds good thank you
thank you thank you matz thank you and
um Jimmy is his mozzarella good would
you would you concede that at
least be mad at me I never tasted it I'm
being honest it's so good it's the best
I ate it many I'm sure it's good but I
never I never taste it I'm not a big
cheese eater I'm being honest but don't
you think
intolerant why okay all right fair
enough fair enough you don't eat cheese
that's fair a cheese Mason you you need
to Mason how are you doing down there
you have any thoughts I dude I'm I'm I'm
zoned right now bro I'm just listen
you're not here more than any no I'm not
here now okay out thank you guys so much
for having me on it was oh it's nice to
see you I
love all right you guys have a good rest
of your night all right you take care go
go chill go
relax poor poor Mason blazed out his
trying to process all this yeah this is
crazy this is like guys what is like oh
my God I I've been I've just my whole
existence on YouTube I've been watching
this show and watching you and now I'm
here and it's like Jimmy is attacking me
live on the air my best friend my
brother the guy who I love with all of
my heart
Jimmy understand I love you
why me please I didn't lie to you let's
explore uh because I feel like Jimmy's
being really vulnerable right now and
this is a good
opportunity Jimmy if he could be honest
as a person about things okay let's go
one by one I don't mind I don't mind
being friends with a person Ethan who
has integrity and who's honest so Jimmy
let me stop you what name first of all
let's name one thing that you feel Alex
lied about let's start with just one
thing and let's start there
well he told me how much he gets paid
for his freelancing gigs it's always
like2 to $3,000 he just told you 500 and
he told you on the air that he never
told me that okay Jimmy a lie that's a
lie so Alex that hurts me makes me not
trust him Ean so Alex did you ever tell
Jimmy you make that much money per gig
when I so when I do work for MTV I make
a lot more money because I work for like
a week and I'll make a day rate got it I
don't know if I'm supposed to be saying
any of this by the way might ruin all of
this for me but anyways the Rock and
Roll Hall of Fame awards was for Disney
Jimmy tried to get a ticket to the show
and then he asked me to get him a ticket
to the show I told him I couldn't get
him a ticket because this my first time
working like with that's true that's
true and he said if you were really my
friend you would do that if you really
cared about me you would pull strings
and do that you said that Jimmy I said
if you if you could pull no I said if
you can pull strings get me a ticket
then you said you said you could do it
if you really wanted to and I said I do
really want to I just can't do that for
this and also like you could have bought
a there were tickets online like it was
like a public event and I just like I
couldn't get you backstage CU I was down
underneath baray Center and like I just
like I was out of my element it was not
like an MTV gig I've worked with them
for like four years this is like my
first time working I gave them a really
good deal to do it because I just like
wanted to be there and be like foot in
the door yeah foot in the door again I'm
really small I'm really really small I'm
brand new yeah Jimmy you understand when
your foot's in the door you're not in a
position to be asking for favors and
stuff you know what I mean he portrayed
to me all the time that he was a big
shot
so called me poor you told me I live in
the do not say I live in
the if I can interject something to go
back to the beginning and thank you Gabe
by the way for sticking it around I
appreciate that that makes me feel
better to know that Gabe's here honestly
that's like taking a weight off my
shoulders do you want to add anything
Gabe it's nice to see you it's nice to
feel your
presence well I'd say it's a war who who
believes who's lying who's believ honest
it's just I can't really tell but to my
thing I think I think Jimmy's trying to
twist tongues to see that he's a liar
but I don't I don't believe it I don't
know so Gabe is saying that he's
potentially getting the vibe that Jimmy
is the one being not
honest I don't think that's true I think
perception is reality and I think Jimmy
I think Jimmy really like I think he
feels slighted by me and that's really
real and I'm like I'm sorry for that I
don't want you to feel like like I was
representing like I had all this money
to you it's just you kept telling me
Jimmy all the time how much of a poor
loser I am you would tell me I'm young
what did I say what did I say that you a
poor loser you made me feel like that
you told me I'm young I have no
experience wait a minute did I say that
hold on hold
on hold on I want to make this totally
clear stop stop what did he say exactly
hold on Jimmy what did he say exactly
Alex what exactly he said to me was
he would he would put these fake
articles in like La wire and stuff like
that and he's like look I added you to
the article and you know I didn't tell
them how young you are how you haven't
worked on anything or how nobody knows
who you are I just called you a topnotch
filmmaker so you felt and and Olivia I
see maybe you were nodding and agree
hold on no Jimmy give one sec Olivia do
you can you corroborate that at all
because I saw you nodding she was there
when he said this oh Jimmy's called me
poor
um like this is new wait what Jimmy has
called me poor before like this is
nothing new like this is I'm not like
I'm I don't know why anyone's shocked
like this is like yeah this is classic
Jimmy she's saying
so he he has he I understand okay Jimmy
I don't know if you can hear me he's
okay right now but I understand where
you're coming from in that he has a way
of being condescending yeah he has a way
with words yeah
yeah but um I mean like do you have any
other questions while he's like um on a
leave of absence that's a good point
well basically
interesting I get the sense that he's
just a real sensitive guy and he he
doesn't have a it's not easy for him to
analyze his own behavior but he has a
really easy time analyzing other
people's behavior and when he feels
slight Ed it it's part of his condition
frankly I believe I think it might be
again I'm not a I'm not a professional
and I don't want to diagnose him but
there are personality disorders that
have fear of Abandonment and fear of
being slighted and fears of being you
know that people didn't really like you
and I think that we're seeing symptoms
of that and frankly Jimmy went through a
really turbulent childhood and so these
kinds of issues really um
can can you know rear their head uh even
even as he you know and so so in a sense
I I sympathize with him but in another
sense I I understand that it would be
hard to have interpersonal relationships
with him uh when he can come down quite
harshly on you
guys um he's coming down with Thor's
hammer on me right now I don't know what
to say yeah like Jimmy he wants to get
famous and like he is a sweet guy guy
but um you know he he has goal in mind
and he's going to put himself first and
like you know um that's his goal you
know ultimate foro so Jim Jimmy uh now
that you're back I understand from Alex
essentially that he felt condescended to
at times like he had mentioned when you
included him in the write up that you
put an emphasis on like that he has no
experience that he's a nobody and all
this kind of things that made him feel
you talking down that again is a lie
because when I spoke to the editor I
said write something Punchy about the
filmmaker so I think one of the Articles
said he's a top-notch New York filmmaker
I would never no it wasn't in the
article it was when you called me on the
phone and said don't worry I would never
tell anyone how young and inexperienced
you are I tell them all you're a
top-notch guy and it's like I I've
worked you know I have my own credits
did I say that to you Alex El was there
she was sitting right next to me when
you said it you said definitely said
that to me Jimmy
okay so are is that an acknowledgement
that uh or or are you denying it that it
happened Jimmy I I I never said that
what I said is I'm gonna paint in a nice
light in the article which I did but
Jimmy is it Jimmy is it possible that
sometimes you
communicate and you're not aware of even
how you're saying how things you're
saying are coming off I think I will I
will say this about me I do say things
wrong sometimes and I come off but my
and my wife will tell you this my heart
is always in a good spot and I love
people and all I want to do is be loved
and I don't have a mean bone in my body
and I will always stand by the people
that that help me and and do right just
like with Alex he is a new guy on the
Block but I made sure in the article
that he was painted nicely because he
did my film and I went on Harry Mandel
thanks to you and I said something very
nice Jimmy just to
analyze what you just said was a little
condescending to
Alex okay and I also told you when you
went on hoe and when you went on the
podcast the first time with the trailer
not to me I kept saying don't mention my
name just let the movie speak for itself
like I don't want to it's like it's not
about me it's about the movie and so
like you just kept focusing on like
returning to me like giving me some sort
of like uh uh quid proquo and then it
what I realized was that later it was so
that you could turn to me and try to
tell me what's what about the Final Cut
of the movie Alex Alex that's not why I
did Alex listen I won't win with you we
did a movie you did a good job I'm not
gonna win with you I'm not GNA fight
with you I'm older that's the end we
were we were best friends I don't
understand why you're suddenly acting
like we're not and and now you've
attacked me on my favorite show I don't
I don't want to attack you I I you just
did I don't want to be B
can I comment pleas my movie and that's
it Alex if I can maybe give some advice
to you is that when working with someone
like Jimmy who is this you know Larger
than Life character let's put it in a
nice way
um that it's I think it's important to
not take things personally as much as
that's possible obviously you're close
with him but Jimmy obviously um he's
he's a funny guy I mean he's the outlaw
so like
it's you you know what I mean like he's
he's a flame he's a hot flame he's
burning you know you got if you stand
next to the flame maybe you get burned I
don't
know um yeah I don't have a mean bone in
my body but when when I get
misled and things
happen that hurt me people aren't honest
with me I don't want to have that
relationship I'm sorry that's all that
makes me really sad cuz I Alex makes me
more sad than you to be honest with you
to be honest with you Jimmy I I didn't
do this for views or to go on the I
never wanted to be sitting here on the
H3 podcast that is like my nightmare to
be honest I'm a watch of this hold on
let him finish Jimmy let him finish he
was in the live chat last week on Monday
according to Mason texting for to call
in okay well he's a fan of the show
that's nothing I was texting a call in
because now it's like about you just
said you never wanted to on the podc
tting in the live chat to go on
week Jimmy hold on Jimmy you're I think
you're You're Building mountains out of
mole Hills as the expression text me he
was on the live chat Jimmy come on to
the show he just said he never wanted to
be on Jimmy that's not that serious I
wanted to talk about the movie now yeah
I was gonna go ahead Olivia it's like
hard for me to even keep track of my
thoughts with like the
peanut um but Gabe uh Gabe what's
happening are you what are you
doing yeah I just ordered something to
eat and I like I hope they don't take my
food away nice I'm still on that's
what's up dude let's get that food going
yeah I just ordered some food I don't
want him to take my food away hell no
good you're the man sorry Olivia go
ahead I had to touch in touch base with
Gabe yeah that's okay we love Gabe yeah
um appreciate the love bro you guys are
the best love
you you guys and I'm glad to be on the
podcast on it's not it's not Friday yet
but it's Monday Monday yeah baby happy
Monday Monday is a goodest day as any my
friend so go ahead Olivia go ahead yeah
yeah so um to keep track of my thought
um oh yeah uh Jimmy is like oh Mason
told me they were in the he was in the
live chat I I mean after the call with
Mike like even I was in the live chat
cuz like every time Jimmy every time
you're on the damn show I'm in the live
chat being like hey fact check that like
like I do too like I'm a f the show like
Jimmy people your fomo crew exists
because of Ethan Klein like
I okay so so like the reason why Alex is
in the chat like saying he wants to talk
is he wants to speak to his work like if
I if I dropped eight bands on a movie oh
you bet you bet I'm I'm oliv it's okay
that he was in the live chat and he said
he wanted to be on but he just said to
Ethan he never wanted to be on this show
I
did hold on hold on he lies no Jimmy
hold on Jimmy I too literal Jimmy you're
taking things too literal just be what
he's saying is I don't want to be in
this scenario I don't want to be in
scenario where I have Jimmy bickering at
me from Cherry Hill I have this person
doing this like I have this person
saying that that's not the scen scario
he wants to be in everyone wants to come
on to the H3 podcast like and show their
work like Alex isn't film and art I'm
just a college student who happens to
live in and that's okay want to be on
but then why did he just say he doesn't
want to be on that was my Jimmy Jimmy
you're I feel like we're focusing on the
wrong things here Jimmy not in the
podcast like this like this this
scenario is not ideal this is not ideal
for him Jim you're you're you're on the
defensive I think you're looking for I
don't like people that lie he didn't
though Jimmy I don't know that that's an
accurate representation for example of
what just happened this is this is an
accurate representation of how things go
with Jimmy if I can speak without being
interrupted Jimmy that like he's
misinterprets something and then attacks
and like what I'm trying to say here is
like I
didn't I didn't want to be on the show I
want to Jimmy to go on the show and talk
about the movie if if you guys wanted to
talk to me maybe but like the whole
design of theie movie is that I don't
have to say anything that the movie
speaks for itself that Jimmy can kind of
speak for the movie and like it just it
it just should have been that and like
it it spiraled into this crazy thing
with Mike and now with this and like now
I'm just like on the show and like
Jimmy's screaming at me calling me a
liar and like and I'm feeling like oh my
God like what what is happening here
like I I just don't understand why why
it's come to this instead of
like like I'm just not in this for the
cloud or anything I just want to make
movies that connect with people and that
was what I thought I was doing here I
think I if I can do this like uh Ethan's
last word maybe uh you know like another
show um Jerry Springer yeah okay yeah um
I didn't want to invoke that name right
okay sorry sorry what we do is obviously
a lot more completely
original um Alex I have to I think maybe
when dealing with Jimmy it's important
to not take things too seriously I mean
he's done so much to people in this crew
that if we were to treat Jimmy if we
were to just take it as it were then a
lot of us would probably be very cross
with him but I do find that with Jimmy
it's important
to again not take things too literally
not take things too personally and
you're not for doing that by the way but
I just feel that with Jimmy he's a he's
a he's a butterfly and what I mean by
that is that he's a unique individual
every butterfly's wing pattern is
different and Jimmy is no
exception and and and and and and then
to to summarize something else Jimmy to
go back to the
restaurant even if you thought Jimmy
that Alex was a big
shot I don't think it's right to expect
him to chip in on this meal I mean
um was this Jimmy brought you guys out
for a meal right I didn't I didn't want
to go to a meal at all I said let's wait
until we see how the movie does and he
wanted to go out and shoot fomo on the
street and I said okay well like when he
goes and shoots that he has his people
with him for the day and he wanted them
to go out to eat a Bazar and he was like
you should pay for it and I was just
like listen I don't even want to come
and I'm not filming the movie anymore
there's no reason for me to like be
there filming or anything and he was
like well you can shoot my stuff for
social media and I was like but I don't
really do that so Jimmy you can
understand
why he first of all even if you thought
he's a big shot I mean he's not a you're
obviously much wealthier than he is I
mean you're a wellestablished uh dentist
for Christ's sake but you can't bring
people out to a super fancy restaurant
then ask them to split it with you I
mean that's just not it wasn't split it
wanted me to pay the
bill how much was the bill do you
remember it would have been it would
have been like three i' I've been there
with him before and it's like $2 $300 I
I think like it it wasn't about the bill
it's that that's how he pays his crew
and he's basically asking me to pay his
crew and it's like you
interesting the only reason Ethan I did
it was he was pontificating of his
connections how much money his big
apartment building and he was like he
had a lot of money with it's still not
right I wasn't pontificating on how much
money I have but but Jimmy it's still
not right to to for the bill on him I I
don't think that even so I I I could
have been wrong on that I just did it
because he was trying to carry on like
he was a big wig that's the that's not
true it was because you wanted to come
to the Rock and Roll Hall of Fame awards
and I couldn't get you in and then you
were like well then you should just the
Mone to do with it Alex money from it I
mean that's Jimmy Jimmy Jimmy hold on
guys Jimmy it's not a roll music awards
has nothing to do with I always said it
because you were acting like a
big shot so check if you're a big shot
that's the only reason I said it Jimmy
he's not lying he's explaining his
perception of events he's not lying he's
explaining do with the Rock and Roll
Hall of Fame it came up one time on a
phone call and it got
dismissed when I told you that I got
hired for it you you got really excited
and you tried get tickets and then you
called me 2 days before and you said can
you please get me in I said I really
can't do it I wish I could and then you
said well how much go and then you said
how much are you getting paid for it and
I said I'm getting paid like 500 bucks
I'm taking a really big deal I'm not
giving them any I'm not making a lot of
money making 2500 you li I said I'm not
making a lot of money on this all right
all
right yeah we're we're rehashing lie
about everything that's all you do is
lie we're done pal we're done I'm not
working with a liar I hate to hear that
sorry life but um I will say that I I
truly believe Jimmy
that I think
you're you're being really and I
understand like um your your point of
view but you're really seeing a lot of
lying and Malice where I just don't
believe there is any that's my honest
opinion from the outside and I think
it's a shame because I think Alex does
really care about you and I think it
really does genuinely hurt his feelings
that that to hear you kind of to
speaking Jimmy you told me you take make
$155,000 a day at your Dentistry um so
if we're talking about how much money
someone makes on
something I never said I didn't say that
I did say say that wait what was that
did you he makes 15 can make a lot of
money I told him that that's true that
is true and you're are you making 15,000
a day uh even now you mentioned that
business is down not often not often but
I said I have good days okay you called
me the other day and said you made
18,000 for the day Jimmy you said you
said I'm the big you said I'm the
biggest earner here nobody earns more
than me did you not say that say I'm the
bigest what what was the context of that
why would why did he call you and say
that he just calls and he gets all
guessed up he just you just said you did
say it Jimmy I said to him in passing
once on a good day I make 15 I did not
call him last week and say I I haven't
even talked to him in a while four days
last time we talked was
Friday Ethan I won't win with this guy
he made a film he did do a nice job and
that's it I I don't really feel we can
belabor and go any with I understand
well he's an okay guy but he's not for
me this guy well okay Sor I just feel
like you've got on my favorite show and
you've soured a lot of people against me
at the very beginning of my
career I wouldn't take it too seriously
I don't think I know but I know but
there's like a hive mind mentality with
chat and I've definitely been there so I
just I just want to say that like you
know Jimmy you know what you're doing on
some level and I really do love you and
I care about you and I don't take it
personally that you're the one doing
this to me Alex I have to disagree I
don't think he knows what he's doing on
any
level well I think in that sense I got
to defend him a little bit I think he
knows what he's doing when he when he's
saying this stuff and trying to paint me
because he knows how people act on the
internet I'll talk to you privately
alone with
Zach at you see how now he's acting like
there's going to be something else and
like Alex there's nothing else it's all
done it's all over guys
so so okay let's let's wrap it up I I
want to say you know was it worth all
the lie I I genuinely feel bad that Alex
you know it seems that you you're a good
guy and you did a good job and that
you're you feel uh genuinely hurt and
Jimmy also feels genuinely hurt it's
just a bit of a sad impath
and it's just it's a shame and I'm sorry
to see it but I think you're both great
guys and I just really wish that
you know we could go back in time I wish
we could go back in time I wish that we
could roll back the clock and walk the
path again and take a different you know
make different decisions that would lead
us down a path where we're all friends I
wish I could go back in time A lot of
times you
know but we got to we got to stick on
the road that we we chose and and I
think you know as we walk this road it's
important to look back and and see where
we've come from and to know that the
people we have crossed paths with
although they may not be in our lives
forever that that Crossing will last
forever thank you for that I like that a
lot but I feel like
the it's all washed away now Gabe do you
have any um anything you want to say
closing
thoughts well it's kind of like over
disagreement especially going out and
people but to me honestly if I'm if I
invite people over I don't ask them to
chip in if they want to add you know
want to chip in and the rest it's fine
but it's kind of like you know I don't
want to waste people's time that's
that's what I
think that's a fair observation for
sure I like that that's a fair
observation don't you think Jimmy yeah
he's right don't waste time especially
when no you're not hearing the no you're
hearing the part you want to hear
here he said that you don't invite
people out and then ask them to pay I
heard that and I I'm going to say I'm
wrong on that okay okay so that's nice
that's nice Jimmy I'm wrong on that I I
appreciate you know what
Jimmy and I do want to say though I know
you're a tough crack to a tough nut to
crack and I do appreciate how you've
been open and vulnerable about things
that I know you didn't want to talk
about so I appreciate that I didn't I
did it out of respect to you and you had
everybody on and I was very quiet in the
beginning and you happen to get it out
of me like you did a year ago when I
didn't want to talk about my family you
got it out of me that's twice can I ask
you um separately because I am a fan of
Alex's documentary and the way I will
say again Alex made a very good movie on
me and I thanked him for that I really
did he did a very good job I have
nothing bad to say about the movie he
the involvement of your brother was
really um a fantastic surprise and
lended a lot of gravity to the story um
what was your feelings about your BR
seeing your brother talk about you
because the way he spoke was very
reconcile he wanted to reconcile he he
it sounds like he really loves you and
misses you and W and wishes that he
could you know uh have a have a life
with you in it he's hurt me tremendously
through awful things he's done to me for
the last 50 five years since I was a
little kid and I I it's not healable
Ethan and one day he wouldn't I'm in the
studio quietly not on the air I'll sit
with you and Zach and I'll tell you
everything and you'll jaw will drop and
you won't believe what he
did the thing he says on the air makes
him look good and makes me look bad I
see because I said the truth about him
and he was kind and nice about me so to
a naked eye they're GNA go Jim is not
they don't know what happened that that
was a great yeah that you don't know and
and nobody knows the pain I've had
Through The Years with my parents and my
father and how mean he was and he did so
many things hurtful and I can't go back
and I can't forgive when a person hurts
me I am married to my wife who is
probably the kindest nicest person whose
family's treated me so nice and they've
done so many nice things for me and I
would die for them and do anything
because they've just done nothing but
love me for me and accept me and I feel
your your your crew is like that before
you came you came late on the last
podcast and I thanked everybody in the
crew for for for um accepting me and
loving me you were late and you can ask
the crew that I believe it I even said
to Dan I I hope you don't hate me and he
smiled no comment I did that and I did
that because I I I don't care about
money I just care about people liking me
and and your your crew's been nothing
but kind and then by accident I saw that
Sam made a cake and I I went and thanked
her and Zach said you're not supposed to
know and I'm an idiot but I said that
was like the kindest thing you did
because little things Ethan mean a lot
to me my wife's families like that so
when you when you saw your brother in
the film there wasn't warm feelings or
nostalgic feelings you felt bitter
because it's it's easy for him to want
to reconcile but their great mystery is
that nobody knows what really happened
between you two yeah and I did ask Alex
not not to put him in because it was
very uncomfortable for me and Alex found
his phone number on his own he called
him on his own and I I politely said I
really I'm not comfortable having him in
and he put him in and maybe it did add
to the movie The only thing I'm a little
bit sad about and I'll and I'll say this
to Alex is that it makes me look bad and
him look good when honestly Ethan I've
been hurt tremendously by him my entire
life he's done awful things to me even
up to when my dad died and he acts like
he wants to reconcile he loves me this
and that but if you love a person Ethan
you support them you nurture them you
take care of them like I would do with
my wife or she does with me you don't
rip them down treat them like and
punch them and screw him and do shitty
things to him okay you said you love me
and that's what you did to me tonight
you said you love me what you did I will
say something I don't really dislike you
I don't like how I got treated by you
when you screamed at us and some of the
other things you've done in the last
week to me I don't dislike you I do like
you you did a nice movie when we were
making a movie together we were very
connected we talked a lot during the day
and I felt a lot of camarad with you and
I shared my most intimate moments with
you and then I felt so hurt when I
shared my thoughts on the movie and some
of the other things you did after the
movie and you hurt me so much that I've
been so hurt by my family it's hard for
me to come back to you and love you
because you've hurt me I don't dislike
you I'm just afraid to get hurt anymore
by people all I do is get hurt and all I
do is always take care of people and do
everything for them and I'm too old to
get hurt anymore so I hope that explains
it better I'm not really a bad person
I'm a good I'm a good person but I've
been been hurt so bad and in the last
week some of the stuff that's happened
with you really hurt me and I I I just
can't go there now maybe in the future I
can but not now let me maybe maybe just
I do want to end with this Alex on your
part do you see why perhaps Jimmy was so
hurt by the way it seems that you you I
really I really yelled at him no I
definitely I what I yelled at him and
I'm and I apologize to for to him about
it many times I did I was really I was
really really really upset when he cuz
he really I mean so hold on Alex so so
sorry to cut you off so Jim
Alex apologizes and understands what he
did to upset you now Jimmy may ask you
this do you understand why Alex was so
angry that he was yelling at you do you
understand where he was coming from he
said to me I'm keeping the film exactly
the way it is I'm not change it I don't
give a f what you and Akira think and
how dare you have Aira watch but Jimmy
do you understand why he was
upset I did ask you not to show the
movie hly honestly Ethan I think he was
upset because you know when you're an
artist and you make and he put a lot of
time and he really did because we talked
a lot and and respect that maybe it hurt
him to hear that I wanted the movie
changed and some things Chang and it
upset but but the way he treated me and
and what and how it whole went down it
was like I just couldn't believe it and
me and Akira we were having lunch and we
just when we hung up I'm like we're
looking at each other like a deer in the
headlight what just happened right but I
think you could be more could is it
possibly you could be more forgiving of
Alex in that sense that it was a high
emotion situation if it was just that
one thing but then other things happen
okay all right so I I need time let's
not dive back let's not dive back yeah
Jimmy my phone's always there if you
want to give me a call I don't really
think Alex you're you're a bad guy I
just got a little misled with you and
heard a little bit on a few things in
the last week I just I got to take a
little break right now I'm Jimmy can I
put it in P like if you do um you take
everyone's teeth and replace it and you
put put it and you're proud of it and
you do all this work and then the next
day they come in and say you know
you this looks like I hate
everything you've done here I would be
upset so I
understand he he this documentary was a
whole set of teeth for him I
know I and I do understand that I do I
really do so I think I think maybe I
don't know if we can resolve this today
but I do feel like potentially we've
laid we've laid some some positive
Foundation here for you guys maybe
connect in the future andan I I want to
thank you for in a roundabout way
showing me a little bit about me so I
can understand myself because a lot of
times I don't yeah and I listening
towards the end of this and I need to
take a little bit of look at me
sometimes and you know understand I'm
not always right yeah I'm a straight
shooter and I'm honest guy you're going
to and there's nobody more loyal but you
know everybody has their faults and you
know I have we all know that personality
Disorder so there's things I don't know
and and listen you've been through such
a such a tur turbulent childhood I mean
can we end on maybe getting both both of
you guys apologizing to each other that
would be really sweet I I want to say
I'm sorry I was hard on you because you
know what Alex I was I don't dislike you
I I was kind of hurt by you with some of
the things that happened last week I
don't hate you that's I don't have
feelings like you toward like my brother
who was just did so many mad things and
I want to say to you Ethan I do really
love you I mean the things you've done
for whether it's getting me on hoe or
coaching me I I owe you like the world
you're like a real friend you really are
you're a
nice I really do I don't know what else
to say you're going to make me cry right
now well Jimmy you're I'm being honest
I'm being honest yeah I understand and I
mean little emotional here our
relationship isn't in question I
understand uh I understand uh I I know
who you are Jimmy I understand I want
you guys at your crew to know that
there's been instances nothing to do
with Alex or anything but in the past
with some members of my crew or whatever
that didn't have your best intentions of
heart first guy I called was Zach and I
told him stuff and Zach would coach me
what to do and a couple times he may
have called you and then called me back
and Zach will say Jim was there Jim took
care of it and Jim will always be there
for you and will always take I
appreciate that you're always loyal
Jimmy no one no one's ever questioned
that you're a loyal I will
give you that my wife's family anybody
has anything to say about my wife's
family maybe because if they're Asian or
anything I'll kill them no
because that's a loyalty I have you do
say that you that well that's just the
character we're not doing character so
if somebody's in character can they say
joke about them being Asian yeah if
they're in character in character what
I'm saying even is how I am with people
who love me and are there for me and
take care of me and and and I I trust
them with my life I will be there for
that person for and ever Jimmy your
apology to Alex I thought was touching
Alex no no I I I do I do want to say
that because I was really rough on him
but I felt I have some Merit and I need
a little time to heal Alex hasn't
tremendously hurt me he's done some
things that's disappointed me so Jimmy
let's on we're building bridges Jimmy
and then Alex is there something that
you want to say to Jimmy uh about how
you handled some things James weiner
Jimmy Lee the Jersey
Outlaw I'm so sorry in the ways that
I've slided you I'm so sorry that I got
upset with you I had never really gotten
upset with JY before ever we've always
just been Buddy Buddy and it was the
first time you'd ever heard me get upset
and I'm sorry I I was in over my head
with this movie and I put so much on the
line um financially and just like
everything I also want to um hold on
don't cut him off Jimmy he's having his
moment oh no because Olivia is I want to
say something nice to her okay well well
hold on one sec let Alex finish let Alex
finish that's my fault no you're good
you're
okay when when we made this I you know I
told you my intention and I think you
know I just care so much about you and
I'm sorry that like hearing you say all
this actually makes me feel good because
I've been texting being like what's
going on like what did I do what did I
do and so at least at least now it's on
a public stage and like I know how you
feel about everything if you love me if
you love me it's you keep saying you do
you have to be you have to love me and
not hurt me you see that that's I hear
you I want to say something to Olivia
Olive are you there Olive she's here
yeah she's there no
not you're a person Olivia who's
believed in me you were one of the first
people on my team a year ago and I will
say something because after listening to
Ethan I think he's right sometimes I'm a
little hard on Olivia on the streets
when she doesn't film exactly right or
whatever because I get I get impatient
and I get I'm I'm I'm a perfectionist
and sometimes I'm a little rough with
her and I I'm going to admit that cuz
I'm and she works for free Jimmy for no
no and I want to apologize for being
like
that that that that girl there stands by
you and and she does love me because
she's not getting anything out of me
maybe a meal I don't think anyone's
doing it for me no no no what I'm saying
certainly not Alex no exactly but what
I'm saying Olivia is sometimes I get
frustrated on the street when I'm not
doing well and then if they're not fil
come on let's go we didn't get any
footage and I just want to say I'm a
little harsher I don't mean it but I I
just like to get out and hustle and get
done so I want to say to her in in
I just want to say I'm sorry sometimes
when I'm a little rough with you that's
there you go that's nice just trying to
be nice that's all do you accept that
apology Olivia from my um yeah I mean
both she's a good person Olivia deep
down you really are deep down no you're
a good kid I
know
know hold on let me go ahead
Olivia um yeah I think
like I think the whole reason why like
there was even like turmoil between Alex
and Jimmy to begin with is because
they're both pretty blatant people they
will tell you how they're feeling like
you know it's not like you can read
their face just like how you can read
mine and I'm kind of like the same way
of like you know I can I can like
sugarcoat things but like yeah I'm like
I I'll be blatant too and like I'll tell
Jimmy he's not funny when he's not funny
so like um I I do understand like yeah
he's frustrated he's in his own head and
like sometimes he says things that are
ofing cuz like I'm just doing this for
fun cuz I love like the H3 podcast like
Jimmy well you're like basically you
used to be in New York you went to
California Jimmy's here for you on the
East Coast my rep over there I
appreciate
that he's my live show in the city in
New York every week exactly come find me
I'm in New York about remember that and
and then Jimmy is there anything you
want to say to White claw Gabe who's uh
mediated this
well I think white claw Gabe's patient
to to still be on and I I met white claw
Gabe at your live show he's a super nice
guy and I didn't get to beat him too
well but um he's he seems like a good
guy and uh a little nutty like us and uh
nothing nothing but nice things to say
about it that's nice all right
appreciate the love I know I know we've
been going for a really really long time
ride shotgun and run New Jersey with me
you shot Rider do we do we have time for
the pit still no we definitely don't
have time for we are way over it's like
listen I J I got to tell you something
this probably make you feel good this
show was supposed to end an hour and a
half ago no way and I kept it going
because I was so compelled by this
impromptu um meeting that I stayed well
beyond and I thank the crew for sticking
around too I think we all understood
that this was a historic moment
apologize that I was a little rough I
I'm really hurting now the movie's fine
I like the movie but I'm just hurting
things that happened and I'm okay now
and I think I'm feeling a little better
since we talked the whole thing out
beginning I really wasn't good I've been
trying to get you on the
phone thank you to
everybody everybody Olivia you J that's
really ni I love you guys a lot I need
that thank you guys and Olivia thank you
for being so nice and taking care of
Jimmy I mean it seems like you really do
a lot for him and and I thank you for
for doing that selflessly that's very
sweet of you well thank you guys for one
like reading the chat and the then
having us in the call especially me
because I'm a little bit more like
random like I could be any revolving of
faces of jimmies you know so like um to
have me on it meant a lot you know shout
out to you guys shout out to thank you
for thank you for changing his diapers
yes thank
you I got I got to cover your Shi Zach
there you go oh there it
is
hey yeah and thank you Alex for the
wonderful documentary and caring so much
it truly is amazing and I hope you don't
feel bad about it it really really is a
great work and you should be proud of it
and I think everyone is really I said
that he did a great job Alex to give you
an idea last night for the fourth time I
was in my bedroom and I was able to
figure out to get a YouTube on my search
on the infinity and I watched it on the
big screen not on the computer D all
right last night yeah that's the way you
should watch it well that's how I watch
it last night so I appreciate that I I
all right you please listen thank you
guys I got to say goodbye I appreciate
you all so much thank you for getting on
the call This truly was a historic
evening and I appreciate you guys so
much so thank you thank you to everybody
and
um what a day I mean my goodness you
never know what to expect here on the 83
podcast you really never do that to go
that you you really never do one thing I
can say for certain is that I truly
believe that everybody's heart is in the
right place here and sometimes you know
things go sideways sometimes things
don't come out the way you did and it's
just seems that sometimes sorry is the
hardest word as El and John is saying
famously and I think I think we
we it's a very human interaction I'm
very grateful for everyone being so
vulnerable it's interesting thank you f
and thank you fidus for Fus your
thoughts on on everything do you have a
closing uh thought and another new
person potentially comes in the your
life it's like you compare what if with
is she more beautiful is she more cool
is she more loving is
she like did you have this as well how
[Applause]
is yeah
yeah
yeah standing over perfidious if we
really Capt off perfectly all right guys
it is so late it's 6:00 I got to
go my computer died I don't know how I'm
going to do the show tomorrow dude
you're getting a Dell all right dud
you're getting a d it just doesn't turn
on which crazy I have to get
more info but uh maybe can figure
something out you come to my house if
you
want I if it doesn't work we just hang
out you could stream from here thank
that's true you could just come here and
just do a a member stream from here
that's true and bring uh and bring the
computer cuz I I could probably take a
look at it I suspect that the the power
brick it's an power supply I think we
have an extra here we could try swapping
it out is a big juicer mhm dude let's do
a PC fixing stream tomorrow oh maybe
that could be the stream yeah lus Tech
tips let's
go troubleshoot that all right guys
love you all so much thank you for
watching thank you to all the members
you guys I run New Jersey I run New
Jersey J no dude I run New
Jersey thank you everyone we'll be back
uh members tomorrow hopefully I mean
yeah I'm going to say 80% chance
tomorrow sounds good but Wednesday 100%
chance boom thank you guys have a good
[Music]
night
when I'm on my own I just know where
you
[Music]
I